that a little bit so why don't you
introduce yourselves and we'll get on it
uh good morning Mr chair for the record
my name is Rob Berry or Robert Berry I
am general counsel to the division of
Medicaid with the New Hampshire
Department of Health Health and Human
good morning my name is Deborah sorley I
am also with the Department of Health
and services Bureau family assistance
I'm administrator for the business and
policy unit thank you
Mark manganello Department of Education
Office of school Finance great well
welcome and let's get on it
sure so Mr chairman would you would the
committee like to hear how the current
data transfer for snap and TANF Works in
practice
that would be fine and how this may go a
similar path yes okay I'll make you go
ahead and turn it over to Deb
thank you I'm not a technology person
but I'm well aware of our process and
procedures and I work very closely with
our systems folks so right now we do
have a data share agreement with the
Department of Education
um and we do what we call Direct
certification for our snap households
that are interested as well as our TANF
population direct certification
basically means if a individual tells us
during their eligibility interview when
they're applying for the snap or TANF
program when we ask the question would
you like your information shared with
the Department of Education to allow
them to understand that you will be
eligible for free and reduced lunch
based on their eligibility with our
program if they say yes we have a little
box in the system that we can check off
if they say no it is their prerogative
to ask us not to share the information
the system is then designed to I'll say
pull all those cases that have said yes
create a data file that is then shared
with the Department of Education the
only information are household names and
information that goes over to the
Department of Education are those that
have identified for us that they're
interested in the free reduced lunch
program
we would be looking to do the Medicaid
in the same way so we would give them an
opt-in opt out during their eligibility
interview with our eligibility workers
and again create a file that would only
share their information if they have
at to that point are there any questions
of them on how that is that in fact
working with that
that condition that box where they check
obvious or no is put is that in place
right now I believe it was in place
until a couple of years ago I was trying
to identify why what might have proper
prior management team to review uh to
remove it but we are looking to
re-establish it so it's in um coincides
with what we would be doing with
Medicaid yes represent Cornell Thank you
thank you for taking my question and
coming here to answer all our questions
I'm going to try is there is there a
large difference in number of the of the
people who would receive
um free and we just lunch if they agreed
to the Medicaid being shared as compared
to the snap and TANF so it's
anticipatory so um our snap and Tiana
households are very eager for their
information to be shared
um so basically what it also allows or
it benefits the the household as they
then do not need to um complete the
application at the at the school level
there it's kind of seamless behind the
scenes for them the Medicaid population
we honestly we don't know
um if they are already receiving snap
and tan if they're already on the file
anyway
um they are a population that pretty
much I'd say you know I always hesitate
to say 100 of the time but I think it's
like pretty close to 99 of the time
they're they're looking for their
information to be shared we could have
different income guidelines in different
populations that are just maybe
receiving uh households that are
receiving just Medicaid
um that may or may not want their
information shared they're not as if
they're not receiving any other
eligibility programs from us our thought
process around this is they could just
not be accustomed to receiving much more
than Medicaid so I think personally we
need to just be sensitive to how they
feel about that for themselves or their
children being identified I mean we
don't they don't need an application but
somehow kids know what kids are getting
free and reduced lunch I think when
they're aligned so you know we have a
lot of self-employed households
um that are utilizing the Children's
Medicaid Program because there's
self-employed and at least they can get
their children and what we don't know
until it starts or are they going to be
as eager to be included or not because
then I personally think there's still
there's still some visual if you will
once the kids are in school so I don't
know the other households are receiving
lots of services so they're pretty
accustomed to it
represent you had your hand up and then
representative cordelli thank you very
much Mr chair and thanks for joining us
this morning um all of you thank you
um is the is the information that's
shared sufficient for the Department to
determine whether a student is eligible
for a free or a reduced
um yeah so in snap and TANF if they are
receiving snap or tnf which is the cash
program with us the arrangement with
those feds is that they are they just
get free the file goes over free
Medicaid it's going to be very different
we are going to have to differentiate
between the income guidelines for free
or reduced and the system is my systems
folks are well aware of that
differentiation and will not have any
problem doing it that way I rather
concern when we eventually get there is
just ensuring that Doe can also accept a
file that's very different than what
they're accustomed to accepting because
right now it just goes well follow up on
this yes it would which is exactly what
you were just saying so this sort of
goes over to to Mark I think
um in terms of what they can receive
make a determination in terms of whether
student is eligible for free or reduced
and then
transmit that and from that information
would then need to be transmitted to the
district for input into point of sale
that's correct so the department is you
know we don't have a fiscal note
published yet but we are expecting we'll
need contract we'll have to we'll need
an amended increase in our contract
Appropriations because we'll have to
amend our systems our software systems
are in-house built to receive that file
and disseminate the information
correctly and with a new level of
precision that we're not used to doing
so we know we can do it we're just going
to need to pay for it and make those
amendments in our software great thanks
so are you talking about another
individual around 160 thousand dollars
under forty five thousand dollars uh not
this would be um I'd have to look at the
fiscal note on what we asked for but um
just a contract Amendment
um I mean we can talk to finance about
that about how much they'd be willing to
appropriate in our contract line item in
our budget but it would be a one-time
amendment to our
um contract so our software developer
can make those modifications and then
ongoing maintenance with be an existing
existing expense in our contract with
our software developers I'll leave that
to finance representative cordelli and
thank you thank you all for being here
um I'm not sure if if I heard correctly
but it sounded like with Medicaid there
had been an opt-in of some sorts that
had been stopped by a previous
administration but you're looking to
start up again I'm maybe you could clear
all that no it's not with Medicaid
because we're not doing anything in the
Medicaid space right now it's with the
snap and tan of households okay
um but the opt-in had been stopped for a
while for snap and TANF but you're
looking to restart that yes okay systems
will run this thing okay follow-up yes
um
maybe
um during the time you're uh up there
um I'd like to hear more about the data
matching process all also but um you
know maybe there's other questions to
take before that
yeah before I go around I'll get there
um represent Heath was in a discussion
just the other day on this and represent
Heath were there any findings or
questions that came up that really need
further resolve from that that committee
that you're on well um I Mary Heath and
I'm actually on division two in finance
and um left to be here in education
um yesterday uh we were having an
information session with doe and Mark
was quite helpful
um what came up yesterday
um in our discussion around adequacy
funding the fact that free reduced lunch
is one of the categories that that
drives
um funding for school districts we've
just gone through covid
um During the period of covid
um everybody was eligible for Freedom
reduced lunch all kids could eat so that
school districts got away from doing the
freedom reduced lunch forms so there's
another aspect that has occurred and
Mark please correct me if I'm not doing
this right because we just had this
conversation yesterday
school districts
you were using during the covet pandemic
the 2019 data and the governor and the
doe they worked out that and they
extended that through 2023
yes the adequacy formula modified f r
data for fiscal year 23 formula fiscal
year 24 formula does not have a
modification on the fnr data so fiscal
year 23 we used we counted about 40 000
f r students Statewide because we
modified the data to match pre-pandemic
levels ratios pre-pandemic ratios what
we're carrying for fiscal year 24 is
around 38 39 000 f r students and we
think there is likely more fnr students
out there than what the data suggests we
told supers all the time as everyone in
this committee knows get your fnr
applications in get them in there
important they're important for not only
feeding kids but for the adequacy
formula so try your best
um we'll it's we'll find out at the end
of the year how how successful they were
getting those fnr numbers up but that's
a that's a funding formula challenge is
the fnr numbers thank you so if I may
yeah so local school districts right now
um I've had some calls about how come my
school district isn't going to get as
much money
um again I've tried to explain all the
scenarios that come about so with a
reduced number of F and our numbers as
well as a reduced student count
school districts may be seeing
reductions so in my mind I think it also
um my work on the direct certification
with with representative umberger last
year brought home to me the importance
that we really have valid data for all
the sources that need this data Mark do
you concur with that
I what I can say is that um
I'm sorry the the data sort of is what
it is
um the data has been uh uh it's been
challenging to get accurate data during
the pandemic
um we're going back to normal processes
so normal processes might bring us back
to normal data sets and if we look at
the fnr ratios after this school year is
completed we might see
um we might see nut ratios that go back
to normal or status quo
um and those might be as accurate as
what leads to historically seeing
um the the concept of Medicaid direct
cert would potentially allow us we don't
know because the data we're just running
hypothetical data but it would
theoretically allow us to identify more
students in poverty than it would be a
new tool in our toolbox to identify more
students in poverty so if we were to go
ahead with Medicaid direct cert and
assuming the Medicaid data the Medicaid
data is a little bit inflated at the
moment because there's no um they're not
kicking uh they're not disenrolling
people but if we assume Medicaid data
accurately captures income and it
actually accurately allows us to to
understand which students are at what
income levels then we identify more
students of poverty we're using a new
tool that we do not have and so that
would make the data more accurate so to
make a long story short in looking at
our FY 23 data where we're okay by 24
the there's a gap and if we were in the
direct program right now we may not have
as much of a gap that we would have
known data coming in is that right
that's a fair that's a fair statement
thank you representative woodcock
thank you chairman I appreciate it good
morning and thank you for taking my
questions
um two simple one question but those
three little thoughts two simple ones
um can you what is the acronym Tana
stand for
oh temporary assistance to needy
families it's a cash and Medicaid
Program okay thank you so it's usually
well it's parents or Guardians well soon
to be Guardians those that are taking
care of children and are in need for
financially and Medicaid all right thank
you and the second part is uh on the
snap and the I always wouldn't be tan as
because temporary is that a annual uh
eligibility or that once
so the both of those programs are what
we call recertified so families have to
re-certify and up constantly give us
current information and the
recertifications are done every six
months every six months okay great
because we have some programs here that
you certify once and never come back
again okay and
the third one is the most important one
or at least for me anyhow uh if the free
and reduced categories uh that we have
now uh with the eligibility that
125-ish 130 or you know we're going
right and we expand that to from 186 to
300 for reduce
okay right now we choose the the top
level is 186. 185 okay 25. thank you so
186 from my thinking 186 up to 300. if
that was passed because that's the bill
that's on the table if that was passed
would the program that Mark is talking
about you're talking about would that be
able to be tweaked to capture those
great thank you thank you thank you Mr
so something you said tweaked a thought
in my head
um
so you have people who let's say like
when my granddaughter when we were
caring for my granddaughter and we
applied so that she would have medical
um we didn't need anything else right
yeah we wanted her to have medical and
so this would be something
would
would she have been would she then be
counted into the total or not into the
total
or would it be up to us to check the box
or not check the box yes so the way it
would be when you came in you applied
you went through a process you you spoke
with an eligibility determination worker
they took all your information down and
during that process you would have been
asked the question would you like us to
share your information with the
Department of Education
so she would be eligible for free and
reduced school lunch
without needing to apply at the school
okay and then you said yes then we would
have you included in the file transfer
if you will if you said no not
interested for whatever your reasons
none of our business you would not be
included in the file that was
transferred okay and and would this be
then a good reason to keep it opt in
as opposed to just automatically
counting her because she didn't need
anything but medical and she certainly
didn't want school lunches
right so in our eligibility system once
you say yes or no we don't go any
further with it then if you're on the
yes because you chose yes your
information would then go over to the
doe file and she would be eligible the
way it is set up now I don't know if
there will be any changes but they don't
have to fill out an application they're
directly certified is what we're doing
shoot somebody at the school would give
her whatever she needed to walk through
the line and get her meals free if you
said no it just stays self-contained in
our system there's nothing else at all
that happens with the information we
cannot share anywhere else while we are
a state system it's called the new
height system as our eligibility
determination system it is considered a
state system because it belongs to the
Department of Health and Human Services
but it is also self-contained and we are
very governed by all the privacy of our
federal Partners on what goes where and
how we set that up thank you very much
there'd be no other information going so
how many people are in Medicaid right
right now and how are you going to deal
with the issue when we get if 601 goes
forward how are we going to get that box
checked on those that are already in the
program Yeah so basically we would have
to determine that to be honest like it
one thing that always is successful for
us when we're making a change is to what
we call
um address or catch the families at
their recertification appointment but
they I do believe I don't have systems
with me today
um but some things that we have done in
the past as we can kind of do we might
do a query back and just kind of be able
to they can still capture we all we have
all their income information within the
system so they would have to just design
the system to run a query as we call it
to kind of catch those families
um I don't want to say definitively no
big deal but our systems folks are
pretty great and these kinds of things
which we dapple in all the time so I
think there's ways we could still
identify them we'd want to get a hold of
we'd have to probably I'm just thinking
a little out of the box of things we've
done in the past they might get a letter
that identifies that we are able to
engage in this process now with the
Department of Education ask them to
check it off and send it in to us
um make a phone call to let us know
they're interested there's a few
different things again I'm a little
outside the box because we don't we
don't have anything designed but ways
that we've worked backwards in the past
are through those Avenues they would
still have an opportunity to opt in or
oh
how long would it take to get this thing
going
ah
so right now the system is very bogged
down with what we're calling all the
Medicaid unwind and changes that are
needing to happen in that area so
anything that we're asking the system to
do new
um we're always asking them to do
something
always we're probably I'm going to say
at least nine months to a year out
before they could take on the project
can't you just talk to your phone and
say Hey Siri
I could step out and phone a friend
I didn't phone a friend earlier but
just just on the timing of the all of
this um there's some unknowns but right
now the pilot is not open so normally
the way the pilot worked last year the
deadline was September 30th 2022 and
then this the Medicaid director
legislation did not uh become a law so
we anticipate them to kind of sort of
open the pilot back up and allow us to
potentially get an application in by
September 30th 2023 3 which would impact
the 24-25 school year for for nutrition
purposes it would impact the fiscal year
26 adequacy formula that's if they open
up the pilot they have not opened up the
pilot so September 30th night uh 2023 is
not a deadline available to us so it's
the next year so the early this could
impact on a school year under current
Paul USDA policy the earliest this could
impact is um school year 26 which is
adequacy 27 but um we'll we'll let you
know if USDA opens it back up I I don't
know exactly the reason why they closed
the pilot
um so we kind of anticipate them to open
it back up but
um that's that's unknown at the moment
okay further questions represent Myler
thank you Mr chair a couple questions
one how many are in the pilot uh and has
there been any uh any results of the
pilot that you can let us know what's
going on are you talking about how many
states are in it yeah yeah I think we
heard weird testimony I don't know this
for myself but we heard testimony that
39 states are in the pilot
um as far as results I only have
anecdotal information from from other
states I've talked to
um just that the benefits that they it's
it's more the policy benefits of of
people not uh uh complaining about the
applications because they went forward
and actually stopped it like
Massachusetts stopped uh requiring
application are you implementing
applications and they felt um that was a
positive policy change from their
perspective
um but that's I don't can't tell you any
results of funding or nutrition just a
follow-up please go ahead of those 39
states are they opt in or opt out
we we want to know that or um I don't
know that okay thank you
represent Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you all for
your help
do we know
what percent of
children who have Medicaid
perhaps in your example of self-employed
people who you know don't have health
insurance without buying it so they
might get Medicaid for their children
what percent of those children wouldn't
qualify for free and reduced if they
who obtain it
thank you and oh yes
sorry brain cramp
um
bye for now
you're welcome thank you very much
representative Heath uh representative
cordelli
thank you uh could you tell me where in
the statutes it provides for the snap
and TANF direct certification data
matching
it's
um
so the way the
yeah it's all federal it's authorized in
federal law so it's uh the federal
government allows to direct certify and
so
um the the Department of Education and
Department of DHHS made that decision um
I don't know when but they made that
decision with a federal enabling
legislation but there was no State
enabling legislation uh they used
Federal legislation
federal federal law representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair
um I wanted to sort of get back to
representative woodcock's question about
the resolution of the um the data up to
um uh between 186 and 300 percent of the
federal poverty guideline and I was
wondering does that resolution uh exist
in the would that resolution exist in
I'm not sure I understand the question
so I guess my question is the the fact
that New Hampshire has has expanded
medicaid Provisions does that provide
greater uh
income resolution in the income data
that that goes
um that I guess that covers families
with incomes between
um 186 and 300 of the federal poverty
guideline and if we were not to have
expanded medicaid would that
um would that income data no longer you
know be available through through our
through the Medicaid
um data I think the only thing I could
say I'm trying to grasp of a question as
well is we will only have data available
for those that have been determined
eligible for a program that we're
offering
right right so that's that I think
that's close to the answer um
but but does does the fact that we have
expanded medicaid
um
get us that that information uh in the
event we were not to have expanded
medicaid would we be able to uh know
when somebody's at 300 percent of the
federal poverty level I would say no I
think I'm on your path so basically if
we did not have expanded Medicaid and
somebody came through the door and
applied and we didn't have expanded
medicaid they would be denied they would
be determined denied for whatever they
were applying for right they weren't
eligible and then once someone is not
eligible their information is really not
captured and maintained in the system
ongoing so there would be no way for us
to do that right so so Mr chair so uh
just just a comment on that so I think
to to representative woodcock's um
question uh it really would be it seems
to me that it would be incumbent that
expanded medicaid
um be in place to to capture that um
those those families that are between
186 and 300 of the federal poverty
guideline
is that how you're taking this yes sir
all right just to clarify something uh
so what representative Woodcock is
discussing and I believe he has a bill
to to try to increase
um state aid to community to feed
students that are between 186 and 300 we
cannot use Medicaid data for that we
cannot use Medicaid data for that
purpose we're only restricted to use
Medicaid data as CMS allows the center
for Medicaid services allows and the
center for Medicaid services is not
going to allow us to use Medicaid data
unless it's a particular program that
program it being the federal fnr program
so CMS would not allow us to grab income
data from for someone over 1 185 to
identify them for a state-run program I
believe that's my understanding and my
research on this topic
yeah great uh yeah that's correct I can
give you the citation on that there's a
very specific uh federal statute on what
we can and can't share for Medicaid
purposes and that's a 42 USC 1396 a
um a
so I have it right here
that would be helpful IR 1396
aaa7 yeah yeah it's it's the Social
Security Act is confusing to read as you
probably know representative Woodcock
and then representative
um thank you for that Mark and all three
of you uh that that response was is um
great information not for happy with it
with great information
um
if if the bill uh so you just tell them
you can't direct start that 186 to 300.
good it wouldn't be all good for initial
Medicaid basically what you're saying
what way we will be able to capture that
electronically if there is any that you
can determine beyond the old-fashioned
paper
not aware of any other methodology that
would be legal for us to to do that
let's just keep our questions right on
601 yeah I know you're trying to tie it
in with another bill but uh oh I
wouldn't do that no I know you wouldn't
people from Conway tend to do strange
things
um
are there any other questions yeah yeah
um if we
if rather than participating when it
comes if it comes in the federal program
if we decide to do this as a state
program
and do you need additional
permissions whatever to be able to use
our Medicaid
for people who opt in
um in order to direct certify free and
reduced lunch
my defer to rock so just so I understand
your question correctly if we were to
avoid or not utilize the federal program
if we were just to utilize a state
program my read of federal statute is
that we can release Medicaid data or
utilize Medicaid data only for the
purposes of administering the Medicaid
Program or this particular program
there's a specific carve out in that
citation I gave you
a minute ago so I don't know if we could
utilize
Medicaid data just for a state run
program I don't believe we could
I no I meant for the federal free and
reduced program do you need anything can
you
use the State Medicaid information to
direct certify
Federal free and reduced program
without having to go through that pilot
program that's my question yeah I don't
okay thank you can you refresh my memory
here when we did expanded medicaid years
back it was around fifty thousand folks
were trying to expand
I've heard through the Bia that numbers
are doubling
is that correct
I can provide the committee with updated
numbers from the department's website
um I don't have that offhand I had it
with me last time but the the number has
gotten out of my head at this point but
I can easily get that it's right on the
Department's website I can provide it
it's on the website we can pick it up
yeah if you go to the uh the Medicaid
section on the website there's a little
tab about enrollment data and it's easy
to find at least I think it is and not
go ahead represent cordelli uh thank you
just wanted to follow up with a prior
question about the uh snap and TANF
direct certification
um is that in rules for the uh either
Department
I'm not overly familiar with the snap
antenna program because it's a bit
outside of Medicaid
um do you have you can get back to us I
further further what about the doe yeah
not in any nhed uh rules not in rules
thank you
as a further further questions I have
one um we've oftentimes heard
representative Cornell I both heard this
that when we're dealing with Carl
Perkins bunny which is another Federal
grant goes to Career Technical education
within that formula there is a poverty
uh uh element which is in that equation
for the numbers that we receive from the
federal government would if we got into
the Medicaid direct program and our
numbers were to increase in in our free
and reduced meals would those then also
apply that increase also carry over into
our other federal grants which are
determined based on poverty
so generally speaking uh just a a
generally the rule for federal grants is
the federal government isn't a huge fan
of f r number they like the U.S census
data for their poverty metrics New
Hampshire is a fan of f r data because
we use almost all of our allocations use
fnr data um so the way just generally I
think this is Trooper Perkins I think
this this is true for title one this is
true for a lot of Grants
um uh they allocate to the 50 states and
the territories using U.S census data
which our fnr numbers would have no
impact on that's based on U.S census's
methodology
and uh and then we allocate out to the
districts or
um yeah out to the districts
um using fnr data so it's going to
change and that's actually
it's going to change the way in which we
allocate out to the district so if we
have 100 million dollars and this
Medicaid direct cert works really well
for certain communities they'll receive
more portion of that 100 million dollars
um in that hypothetical so it's going to
change the way we distribute the state
distributes out to the uh districts
thank you further questions
that interrupt interrupted my brain but
it was very important
um
if we
if we do the federal Medicaid direct can
we still do opt-in opt out or will all
of our data
end up being shared with the federal
government which
Medicaid people may not want their
information shared with the federal
government so how will that end up
working
I'll have DHS speak but NHS is not
giving any individual information to the
federal government if the federal
government asks for information it's
it's it's it's a roll-up but we're not
giving any student information to the
federal government
or or parent or any individualized
information to the federal government
and the department plans to design the
system with the opt-in opt out and as we
spoke about previously if you opt out
don't want it to go it doesn't go beyond
our system that stays in-house goes
nowhere
thank you
well I want to can we just go over the
the data matching
sure
how would the data matching
it work yeah it's the way the current
system works and um I know DHS can
explain it in more detail but just to do
a high level explanation it's
essentially
um
DHHS has their data which is snap and
TANF um and then if Medicaid were added
would be Medicaid included
um the way we match it's basically I
like to say A robot's doing it it's a
computer doing it it's not a human doing
it but it's based on an algorithm
um and the algorithm is matching date of
birth first name last name and residence
um I believe in gender as well and it
has a particular algorithm to a match to
know this this is the exact same person
the person then the DHHS data set is the
same person we have in our school
information systems so the robot's doing
that matching
um it's it's a pretty good formula or
algorithm because it's it's it gets a
lot of them sometimes it kicks out
something and says we're not sure about
this do you want to put do you want to
double check this and so a human does
look at that matching and then goes yes
that is a match that's clearly a match
Kayla likes to use the example they
spelled Caitlyn with a K instead of a c
but we know this is the same person
because of all the other factors so
there is some human element to matching
but mostly it's done through a computer
software program but that's how that
those are how those files match
anything else from the committee right
now I want to just verify
um so it's date of birth first and last
name residence and gender
yes and I think middle initials in there
thank you very much uh Deborah and Ralph
and Mark
um I appreciate your taking the time out
of your busy schedules come in here
today and help us out with some of these
questions thank you very much Mr
chairman I do have the citation I read
to you earlier how would you like that
delivered
boy would be great if we just get a copy
of that um I can I can give you this
copy here or I can send it to you have a
fax machine over there you know I do but
I don't know how to use it if somebody
can go take a picture of it with their
camera I'll help you out I don't mind
yeah general questions too
so not not directed to what you are not
directing them but we could take a
picture willing yeah yeah but but this
is sort of a question sort of going out
to the the um the the former uh
principles and superintendents who are
who are in the room but we've talked
about this anecdotally I think around
around this table the amount of time
that building principles
um
spend trying to chase down a student
family paperwork for this and and not
just talking about from the standpoint
of of um of making sure that that that
uh that kids are are fed certainly
that's that's important but as Mark
pointed out also the the school funding
formula has a significant amount of um
of of money that's uh that's that's
appropriated based on uh our our poverty
metric which is which is is gleaned from
free and reduced price lunch counts but
but Rick I mean you must have some so my
experience as a as a principal and and
and Cascade is not here as a
superintendent we have uh representative
Woodcock too
a lot of time in the office with your
your secretarial staff I I had an
elementary school with about four or 500
kids in it and I had three secretaries
in the office and one was allocated to
do this task uh and getting the
paperwork in it took an inordinate
amount of time then we're starting to
sit down together as principals from
other schools within the same district
trying to match our data this is prior
to the use of the technology which we
have available right now right yeah
you know we we were actually we were you
know we were uh really ahead of things
in terms where I was in terms of
Technology than they were in the lower
48 even because we had to have it so but
uh it took a lot of time a lot of money
uh was involved in this uh certainly if
we could have something done why I don't
like to see robots doing everything but
you know making those decisions and
choices but I to me anything we can take
the paperwork out of the office and
having that stuff pile up somewhere else
in the central office
it's just horrendous amount of time and
paper that we're using
reps on Woodcock I don't know if you had
the same type of feeling yeah and thank
you other than that exactly the same
except was worse at the high school
because those young because we're very
reluctant to saying that the role over
now with that doesn't happen is terrific
uh our biggest concern at the high
school level was last loss of
subscription because we couldn't capture
those kids yeah we had lost paperwork
and backpacks and school bus floors and
all this other it blew all over the
neighborhood and never got home to Mom
and Dad and so we had to chase that down
yeah and we see a huge waterfall effect
between the Middle School and the high
school in terms of participation in the
program huge and and uh there's a lot
more to it there uh esteem and all that
other
so I want to once again thank you I know
you got to run to other meetings we have
other bills which we have to address
right now getting into the finance stuff
the mark you're not off the hot suit
so thank you very much again thank you
now is there any more discussion like
you were on this yeah on 601 is that 601
before we get into we're going with it
so so this work session on 601 do you
see any uh any
um
I guess technical amendments that would
need to be addressed in this committee
uh uh prior to uh hopefully I mean I'm
hopefully a successful vote out of
committee a successful vote on the floor
and thus going to finance uh with uh
with and giving Mark time for a fiscal
note and um and costs for the department
and things like that what I would
suggest I had a long conversation the
other day with Karen umberer she's no
longer in as a representative but she
was one that was the cheerleader for
this program
um in previous years you well know right
and I think yeah and I was we were on
that and and uh I think what we have to
do is in any amending structure which we
do we have to work in conjunction with
division two
and so the next thing that I would do is
say you know and you know the finding a
way to protect that information of the
parent and allowing the parent doesn't
want to enter this program having that
opt out that and that was what Karen was
talking to me the other day about a
wraparound we got fixed this somehow it
sounds like we have a possible
resolution to how to do that and so that
would have to be stipulated with
anything we do and I'd like to work with
division two and this committee together
to try and get that amending language
that's necessary and we're running out
of time on it
um in terms of six months should we do
the opt out
um language yes absolutely yes and
that's what that's what I'm saying and
and then I want but I want to work with
you know everybody's been working with
these folks right here to make sure we
get it written properly and if you have
any suggestions of how we might amend
this bill with opt-out language in in
I always make the joke I have six or
five attorneys sitting out there I got
another one sitting on the bench back
there right now and I get six or five
different answers yeah Mr chairman I'm
happy to provide some draft language for
the committee to review and deal with a
uh that would be very very helpful with
it and you know and if you could also
just uh clean it up a little bit could
you also work with Dina Fenton back
there in the back she's she's the
prosecutor for
she's ex prosecutor she's doe attorney
and with Mark and so absolutely great
thank you
further representative Damon thank you
Mr chair I just briefly wanted to say
this goes back so long in time so quick
personal anecdote my mom was a school
lunch director in the Berkshires for
like 25 or 30 years
in a K-12 six town seven Town Regional
School District
and I so remember her tracking families
when the kids would drop off and not
return the forms she'd say I know that
family will qualify and she personally
Reach Out
on the phone at night before all the
technology and here we still are and we
haven't made it easy for kids to get fed
in the old days though a principal could
make that decision
and we would check them off and they
would be in the program because we knew
what the income was
we didn't want a kid starving
okay thanks again I've said that several
times since I really appreciate it and I
would we look forward to any kind of
hey
have a good day
pardon me you might just stay right
okay uh looking at the other uh areas
which we want to look at today uh 529 is
relative to additional a grants for
schools based on free and reduced price
meals and fiscal capacity disparity I
think that's a good one to just address
right now the other ones are relative to
relief and calculation and determining
grants for adequate education very
similar uh 540 relative to adequate
education grant amounts for pupils
receiving special education services I
think we're on the track on the road
with a special education services uh
um you may have a little bit more
information for us on that one so Mark
um in looking at 529 and I I
representative
um
you know fellows is there
relative to the additional grants for
schools based on free and reduced price
meals and fiscal capacity
disparity Aid can you speak a little bit
to that where we are on that or are
there questions for our Mark first let's
go that way are there questions from the
committee that you want me to represent
Lexus
all of this conversation and something
that was said about other states got me
wondering and I don't know whether this
is something you can answer
but is there a reason why the state does
not our state uses free and reduced
lunch rather than
um
Census Data because apparently other
states do and can you explain any of
that
so I can only explain just sort of the
the oral history that I've received uh
historically when people look at census
data and they look at fnr data
the Census Data disorder doesn't pass
the smell test so there's certain
communities that all of us know are are
kind of wealthy and they're showing up
as
as poor essentially so I think that's a
historical like this historical policy
decision that's meant to rely on f r
data census data is a survey survey has
a margin of error so when you count a
student there's
there's no real margin of error you're
not surveying them and asking them how
much income there is there's a student
there's documentation to support that
that's a student is in poverty so the
state of New Hampshire is just relied on
having a student having that full audit
Trail to know if that student's in
poverty or a census is however U.S
census does their methodology their
methodology it may have improved over
the years but um the state has just
historically felt f r numbers were more
reliable than the census
thank you Jefferson Belcher thank you Mr
chair just to follow up on that line of
thought if the Census Data isn't great
do you are you aware of any data points
that are comparable in um to the free
lunch program that are available either
from the federal government freely with
no strings attached or that exist within
the state
so we've studied this before
um so ideally if the IRS would open up
their Data Systems which they're not um
we would have great information that's
not available to us
which is a good thing I think
um uh so no there's no um some states
have income taxes so they have a lot of
income data on their families we don't
have an income tax
um
people have looked at other data sets
they're usually the problem with
adequacy is we calculate adequacy at the
very granular Municipal level some of
the employment security data is really
rolled up and they're not going to
capture a small small town another
unique thing about New England and New
Hampshire is we have 244 municipalities
in a very small area some of the bigger
states are more County run and they roll
up their they roll up their data to a
larger thing a larger entity so they
don't have to get as granular so here in
New Hampshire we do have to get granular
we do have to calculate at the very
Municipal level so the only data sets
that really allow us to calculate at the
municipal level is f and our data
Medicaid data and then data we don't
have access to which would be like the
IRS
um
and then your census data um but those
are the kind of options available to us
there's no other no one's ever found
another data set that is really
satisfies all those needs to be accurate
be granular and something we can easily
roll into our in allocations
thank you
we have a grant we call the
extraordinary needs Grant
um I think it was it's somewhere maybe
14 million dollars 14 plus million
dollars but it's going to decline by
about five million dollars why is that
so
um the extraordinary needs Grant is uh
it's a it first produces a metric which
is equalized valuation over F and our
numbers yes and then that um if you have
a lot of property value
um you have high equalized valuation and
you have low f r students it produces a
high number and um and you get less
money or no money and then if you have
low property values and
um High F and R counts produces a low
amount number and you get more money
based on how the grant structured though
the the metrics we're using are set in
statute and do not ingest with inflation
so right now as property values go up
it's going to make every Town based on
the way the formula is structured every
town every Community look wealthier
because property values are going up so
the way we measure property wealth is
not
um to distribute the grant is Frozen in
Time based on how it's structured in
statute it does not move with inflation
um that's one aspect of it the other
aspect is declining fnr as we have
declining F and R numbers it's going to
make students communities look
um uh it's proportional but um as we is
declining up in our numbers it's going
to make students communities look less
poor than they were wealthy otherwise
yeah we'll make them look wealthier so
over time the way that grants works it's
gonna
distribute less money because it's going
to the the the formula and the grant is
going to make it's going to make it seem
like communities are wealthier than
maybe they really are because it doesn't
deal with other Market factors right
that's the subject of the next um Bill
too 435 I know and and is the CPI going
to fix this it's not going to fix that
you could it's going to help but you
know on every biennium but it
it's not going to stop inflation from
impacting all this so the extraordinary
needs Grant isn't adjusted for inflation
it's set in stone
um if you wanted to make it float a
little bit better you can make
modifications to the formula I think uh
representative Aladdin representative
Luna I think we had this conversation a
few years ago when you were designing
fiscal capacity to disparity Aid whether
you could let it float or not and um
there's no I think we you have to Noodle
around with the legislation on how to do
that
um you could probably just come with the
the bill that's up next after this one
um throwing a CPI on the grant is going
to boost the numbers so that's going to
help it flow better
um in perpetuity
um throwing a CPI the grant amount I
think is 650 per each fnr student so you
could throw a CPI on that and that would
go from 650 to say 680 to 720 and that
would help the grant produce more money
um then you could also put a CPI on the
EV values or you could say you could
write uh legislation that says this
shall track whatever the property
division within Dr Ray says is the in
change in property value so right now
we've had property values go up a lot
more than CPI they've gone up 18
um because it's CPI is a bundle of
services so you could you could you
could make amendments to make this thing
work to make this grant work uh better
in perpetuity and not have this 5
million dollar decline but that would
require some some amendment to law
then the other side of the coin we have
a a grant for 17.5 million dollars
I'll explain that a little bit
yeah so this is the this is the
challenge with um uh
the relief 8 Grant not the extraordinary
needs Grant which is a bill before in
this work session next to deal with that
is it's set in stone to be 17.5 million
so it doesn't float whatever the numbers
are it doesn't matter well it does
matter because it deals with the
allocation but it doesn't matter for as
far as how much money we spend in total
it's always going to be 17.5 million so
we prorated up or prorated Down based on
that just based on what set in statute
which is 17.5 million uh so getting that
formula to float
um the the bill that you have in uh in
front of this committee is we do a CPI
adjustment to the grant amounts and so
that allows it to grow with inflation
um f and R numbers are still going to
move around
um so that's going to impact the overall
Grant but it's gonna
get rid of the proration which we we
requested getting rid of the proration
because it creates an administrative
burden on how we do Cooperative
apportionments that's really into the
weeds um that's more it's kind of a meat
problem but we're asking you to help us
out here
um because it's a lot of work to track
all these dollars
um but if you if you have it with CPI
you could have it float and the formula
would do exactly what it needs to do and
not just give out 17.5 million
um on a regular basis it would give
whatever the numbers however the numbers
fall that's what it would give out
and going back a couple years we had
fiscal capacities varied at
approximately what 40 something million
dollars
um explain how that's arrived at and
maybe that's where we've got to start
entering in a little bit of what uh
represented fellas has here
yeah so for those news to the committee
the way in talking about different ways
to measure poverty a lot of the
conversations for the past five years
we've had about Equity there's a lot of
different ways to talk about Equity but
a lot of the work this committee has
done and study committees have done to
talk about measuring defining Equity
it's a very it can be a very subjective
conversation and everyone has their own
opinion about Equity but the body of
work done by this committee
F and R numbers is a way to talk about
Equity where the fnr students are that's
a way to talk about equity and then
property value is a way to talk about
equity and those are kind of the two
tools in the toolbox in which this
committee and other committees have
talked about Equity
um
so the representative fellows uh bill
there's an fnr uh distribution in her in
her bill which focuses on just the fnr
and then there's something called fiscal
capacity disparity Aid So Physical
capacity disparity Aid is similar to
extraordinary needs Grant but it only
looks at property values and does not
look at fnr numbers so fiscal capacity
disparity a similar formula property
values over students not just F and R
students it's property values over
students so if you have a lot of
property value and not a lot of students
that's going to produce an equalized
valuation per pupil and so that number
is going to be really high and so what
um what you might say is for each
student in that community in which they
can tax from their tax base they have a
larger tax base to pay for the education
of one student that's what equalized
valuation per pupil is measuring
um and then if you have a lot of
if you have low popular if you have um
uh low property values and a lot of
students that's going to produce a
really low number for equalized
valuation per pupil and then what that
would tell us was for each student in
that uh Community they have a low tax
base in which to raise revenue local
taxation Revenue to fund that student
um
sometimes when you look at a spreadsheet
with 244 municipalities sometimes you
have a community that has kind of decent
property values but they have a lot of
students so these are some of the
Suburban towns sometimes you'll see them
show up if you look at if you look at
representative spreadsheet
um you'll probably see this in your own
research because they have a lot of
students they're tax base per pupil is
actually kind of small so that's how
when people analyze uh these bills
they're usually looking at fnr numbers
they're you looking at property value
um and they're then they're looking at
the Town by town and seeing okay what is
the distribution of tax base in the
state what is the distribution of
poverty in the state and that's
typically how these how these uh things
get analyzed
so this thing goes around and around
yeah representative yeah thanks thanks
Rick and um and you know you were you
were alluding earlier I think to the the
work we've done in in hospital 709 in
2019 and 2020 and um and I think Mark's
point about the um the property values
changing a lot obviously they've changed
a lot in the last uh in the last four
years because I was just looking at
House Bill 709 and when we did that so
just a few years ago that um the the
equalized value per pupil range was 350
000 to a million dollars yes it was and
that covered the low end to about the
halfway point and now to cover that
range it's six hundred thousand dollars
to 1.6 million dollars and and I think
Mark's Mark's observation that look
that's not tied to a CPI that's New
Hampshire property you know and and you
know real State Property Dynamics and
and it may be something that we're going
to have to revisit in statute to to you
know update uh either increasing it or
decreasing it depending upon how how
property values uh fluctuate you know in
order to provide some stabilization in
the no I don't want to use the word
stabilization to provide some some
predictability
um for uh for school districts
yeah
uh my my concern is I'm looking at a
Lincoln
and Woodstock area and property values
are
up there
income poverty is very existent and so
so any formula we have I think we're
going to have to take in account both of
those factors well in in 529 does that
yeah
components yeah to it
are there other questions from the the
committee here Urban
no thanks thank you thank you
just trying to pick your brain
um
property values
my understanding it's based a lot on
what's recently sold
Etc is and
if you're not selling your property
it it really has no effect on you what
what money you have to pay
for instance
property values have skyrocketed in my
town because there isn't a lot and a lot
of people want to live there
um which makes everybody's property
values real high but it doesn't make
everybody's income real high people who
aren't selling their houses aren't
gaining and so the property values can
go up and go down but it doesn't change
how what people can pay is there a way
of kind of
I don't know trying to get a clue as to
what people can pay as opposed to
how desirable the property in their town
so in that getting like you're you're
talking at a more individualized basis
in a self-contained Community like a
town and homes within each Town
um as far as and then you're you're
linking it to income
um there's no program that that can be
done
targeted based on income through the
adequacy formula because we don't have
an income tax there's no there's no
metric there's nothing we can do for
that
um as far as if property values go up in
your community but your income is low
there's the uh
do you hardship the hardship program
that's um that's not really in this
committee um there's been bills to talk
about the hardship program about if you
are low income and you can qualify
um so there is a program within dra to
give property tax relief to low-income
families
um that that's a separate program
um but yeah I think I think you make up
a good point is sometimes
um well
you were talking about those that don't
have a lot of income and the property
taxes go up it doesn't change anything
for them uh it doesn't provide any real
income for them it provides them wealth
but not income
um but yeah the way the way taxes work
is if if everyone's property value goes
up at the same time and the school
budget says um flat
um their tax rate goes down uh their tax
rate goes down so their net tax impact
is zero making all those assumptions so
that's kind of no harm no foul they're
paying the same amount of taxes they
were they just happen to have a lower
rate because all property values went up
in the community
um but yeah that's that's that's yeah
there's nothing but as far as matching
talking about income the only vehicle
the state has to address to Target
income poor people who pay property
um yeah
so that works within a town but I'm
looking at across the state and we're
trying to distribute this money across
the state and how can we get an accurate
picture
um across the state when
property values aren't necessarily going
up
Universal you know consistently so you
have areas where it's going up in areas
where it's not so then it looks like oh
they're becoming richer when the reality
is they're the same as they were just
their property is more valuable but that
you know so so we may be assuming that
say because or like he was talking about
because you have a ski area and you have
some people and the average you know the
property value is high but the people
who were there Maybe
that may not be affecting them at all
and so but we're looking at a state
thing so how do we take that into
consideration on the whole state level
when we have fluctuation in areas which
affects what that area is going to get
from the state but it doesn't actually
represent their actual ability to
provide an education yeah just two
points you're absolutely right wealth
and income are two different
measurements your wealth can go up your
income can stay flat you've got a
problem you've got an income problem
you've got a wealth you you're doing
well on the well side you're not doing
well on the income side those are
completely detached and when looking at
equalized valuation per prop per pupil
we're looking at wealth we're not
looking at income the only way to look
at income is to look at fnr and another
thing one another thing that comes up
we've talked a lot about like the town
of Lincoln
um uh uh when we analyze towns like
Lincoln there's other towns there's
community that have great property value
but they have working working poor
um they have a pretty a sizable amount
of blue working poor families that are
in there and that that shows up in the
data that's just not Lincoln that's a
multiple communities
um
but but yeah that's the income and
wealth are are two different metrics to
we had a physical capacity disparity
separate column in the formula years
back going back even when we put this
all together
but right now what do we have in there
besides the extraordinary needs Grant
and the relief Grant to account for this
this issue we've been talking about here
the poverty that exists
within the state of New Hampshire we do
we don't have fiscal capacity column
anymore do we no
that's gone
and of the we used to have the cut off
at 48 and then fortunately we got rid of
all the waterfall effect for all those
different categories and it's just a
slide right now and that's much better
however are we seeing more students in
the in school districts in the state
that are qualifying for that 48 percent
now as as result of free and reduced
I suspect no because the f r numbers are
down but I don't know for certain
okay
are there further questions of the
department right now on all this funding
no no
not for this part for us now well let's
start having a conversation ourselves
because this is a work session yeah so
um don't go away Mark
so so this sort of along the lines of
the um of the of the
capacity to to pay taxes and um and I
think taxpayer fairness and and uh and I
I think that's what house bill 529 is
going after is taxpayer fairness in
terms of the fiscal capacity disparity
Grant and student fairness
because it goes to the free and reduced
price lunch Grant which recognizes that
um that that school districts that have
a higher percentage of um of students
that come from low income backgrounds it
costs more to educate all of their
students
um
um because of that connection with uh
with poverty but just taking a couple of
data points I mean we've looked we've
we've we've mentioned Lincoln already
and so they've got a total all in I'm
looking at the dra21
tax rates
total all in and Lincoln is 10.54 cents
per thousand
um in in Berlin it's
36.54 cents per thousand and in
Newcastle it's 4.78 cents per thousand
so um so when you just sort of you know
finger in the air when you do a 50 Cent
cut or 50 Cent reduction
um in let's say the Statewide education
property tax for you know across the
board Statewide how it hits those towns
um Lincoln would basically see a um a
five percent uh tax reduction Newcastle
would say a little about a 12 percent
tax reduction and Berlin would see more
like a one and a half percent uh tax
reduction so that's when you do a a
straight take 50 percent uh 50 cents out
of the out of the out of the swept but
you know when we when we sort of zoom
out or zoom in actually to uh to the
individual families
um and I don't have this data at my
fingertips but I'm sure the dra would
would be able to help us with that if we
looked at the median home price in
Berlin and let's just finger in the air
call it three hundred thousand dollars
and the median home price in Newcastle
finger in the air 2 million two million
dollars
um both those homeowners are paying
about ten thousand dollars a year in
local property taxes at that at those
the 4.78 rate in Newcastle in the 3654
rate in um in Berlin and and while we
don't as as Marx pointed out have data
that that suggests or that data that
that says that the homeowner in Berlin
has any different fiscal capacity or or
income than the homo owner in in
Newcastle I think Common Sense suggests
that the homeowner in Newcastle living
in a two million dollar home
probably has greater
resource access to resources than the
homeowner in Berlin uh living in a three
hundred thousand dollar home I think
that's just sort of common I think
that's common sense
um because they're both and they're both
they're both essentially being assessed
the same
um the same amount of total property
taxes about ten thousand dollars each I
know in Hopkinton I pay a lot more than
than than both those uh examples and I
think that's probably true in a lot of
other
communities around the state and uh and
and that's that's exactly what house
bill 529 is going after it certainly
doesn't doesn't level the um uh the
field but it provides some some property
tax relief in the in the towns as as
Mark has has pointed out that have the
have relatively low
um amounts of of taxable property and
relatively higher
um uh numbers of of students living in
those communities and um uh you know to
provide a little um a little you know
property tax relief to where it's where
it's needed most I think it's it's it's
hard to make a case that that the um
that the that the homeowner in Newcastle
has uh has the same
um
access to resources as or that the
homeowner in Berlin has the same access
to resources as the homeowner in
Newcastle
that's just my comment
I I I just like to maybe retort a little
bit uh when we're when comparing a
Newcastle to a Berlin then you want to
look at okay let's look at the whole
scope of the taxes what is the municipal
tax rate in Berlin what is the municipal
tax rate in Newcastle and why is the the
municipal tax rate in Berlin so very
very high
um what kind of services are they having
and have they over built their services
so is in other words the total tax bill
you get is going to incorporate all
those
all those Services all those costs and
so are we seeing that the homeowner up
in Berlin is having to pay a whole lot
out of their little bit of money
um but are they is that a result of the
local Municipal select board or city
council making that decision and whereas
in Newcastle they may not
sure and and and I think that's I think
that's a really good point and you know
uh
certainly drilling down on on those two
examples because I think you're really
talking about you know ends of the um of
the spectrum here but also Manchester's
in this in this as well and uh I mean
Manchester's in the news every day for
all sorts of different you know uh
matters and I'm not going to sort of
qualify what what what that is but uh
but you know the largest city largest
population in the state are obviously
going to have
um
um uh
you know obligations and and
responsibilities that that go well
beyond what we have in Hopkinton in
terms of Public Safety and and and and
things like that but um but I think you
know if you're going to to your point
Rick
um you know when you when you're looking
at a a a a a a a flat
um one size fits-all tax rate cut versus
what 529 does which is provides a
graduated you know slope you know of of
tax relief
um you know a 50 cut off the swept
basically reduces the the new castles of
property owners living in the two
million dollar home reduces their ten
thousand dollar uh tax bill to eight
thousand dollars and and in Berlin
living in the 300 000 home reduces their
ten thousand dollar tax bill to nine
thousand nine hundred
um ninety five dollars probably or nine
thousand nine hundred dollars certainly
not the same level of uh level of impact
and and and I think
you know again to your point Rick
um the the the
um the services that are probably being
provided in Berlin aren't being provided
because they're they're they're cup
overflow with with money but because
they need to do that but in the in the
in the flat tax cut World Berlin
receives almost nothing and Newcastle
who pre and they probably don't need to
provide
many services you know in Newcastle
right receives a 2000 the average
homeowner receives a two thousand dollar
two thousand dollars off their ten
thousand dollar you know tax bill so so
I think that's that's exactly what
representative fellows I think is so you
know aptly going after here with the
graduated
um um approach just like what what you
and I worked on together four years ago
representative
yeah to follow on what you were saying
and remembering back when we used to
have what were called donor towns and
receiver Tower whatever
I remember
our town
um which at the time had pretty good
property values we are very fiscally
conservative we our town hall is still
our Old Town Hall I mean it's you know
probably pushing 200 years old and
and we have a huge population that we're
servicing and there'd be other towns
that have these big fancy buildings that
they built
and yet
and so their expenses are high their
expenses are higher because the local
people chose to spend the money on those
things and the same thing goes with the
schools because the local
property owners are voting on what they
are spending their money on we can see
great disparity and yet we're just
looking at oh this property in this town
so they can pay this much money and they
can't and I remember there were people
in my town one of the things I heard all
the time is why should we be paying for
your fancy Taj Mahal fire department
when we were at the time still in our
original but we have rebuilt the fire
department but
I mean we rebuilt the police the fire
and the town hall is still the same old
building in the center of town because
we don't choose to spend the money and
so once you start it's just something to
think about is that how much towns have
how much the schools cost how much their
taxes are how much things also is a
local decision and it's not just oh they
have or they don't have
it's a local decision what they want to
spend their money on and we might have
and choose to live frugally and they
might not have and choose not to live
frugally and and you have to
it's
anyway it's just something to go into
the conversation that I want to throw
out there that you have to look at that
too that's all
represent Tanner
um I guess first of all I wanted to say
that
it sets up a vicious cycle
uh with these towns like Berlin
Manchester Newport that the more they
the more they struggle
with their with their tax rate the more
or their taxes and their schools need
more services the town needs more
services versus a town that's wealthy
that also is maybe a tourist area
um but wealth brings in wealth more
people want to move to a town if they
have means where the school is good and
where the town services are good
um and shy away from
the towns that don't and so do the
businesses the businesses want to go to
towns that are doing well versus so it's
it's a vicious cycle so it's it's very
disruptive through the whole thing but I
don't think that's what we're talking
about in 590.
um I think we're talking about
um you know disparity Aid and and these
other factors are relevant they we see
them all the time but I don't think that
this is what we're really
we've gone off the rails a little bit
well we've gone up there rails a little
bit but in all the bills which were
requesting a financial note uh in terms
of even like School building Aid the
physical capacity is built medium family
income is built into that formula
and
the poor Community is just going to end
up with older and older buildings that
aren't going to be renovated unless they
can hook into some state aid
and
um I I I don't see that any resolution
of that coming forward because that
formula is is as two sides of the
equation there in terms of where the you
know what we based up receiving the
money on
and so I think this issue of f r and
poverty and how we can you know help the
districts which are in despair we need
to figure that one out and we need to do
it quickly
represent Milo
oh thank you Mr chair you know I I don't
know about the rest of the committee but
I rely on frankly those who understand
numbers better than I do
my concern
is that these numbers are what drives
equal educational opportunity
and that's my concern
that those children that are in low uh
poverty wealth towns
need to be able to have the same kind of
educational opportunities as those that
are in wealthy towns
and so as we begin to look at these uh
various formulas Etc
that's that's the screen that I look at
is that how can children in Newcastle
and in Berlin
have similar opportunities here for a a
quality education
and we can get into the discussion about
well money doesn't count you talk to
Korean cascadden about whether or not
money counts in Berlin
and when she has to close the school
because she doesn't have the kind of
money that can keep those schools open
that's my concern and I think what of
529 and
um
for
um yeah 435 is trying to address that
sense of parity
so that children do have an opportunity
an equal opportunity across the state
and so as I'm that is the screen that
I'm looking at and I I will I will be
very honest with you all I don't
understand all the numbers maybe you do
others understand that and David and I
worked on this and we we've kind of said
I deal with all the policy question
about what's fair and he says well
here's here's a here's here's a funding
and formulas that drive that fairness
and
um I know Mark has been working on this
thing too and trying to provide a fair
opportunity for kids across the state
and that to me is what what's the
Bedrock of these two bills is how do we
provide fairness and I know Rick has
worked with us on on trying to deal with
that too and so um I just Mr chair I
just want to say kids haven't been
mentioned yet in this conversation
and that's my concern is for this where
the students are in this conversation
thank you
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair
supports the values that representative
Myler just spoke about the kids
2120 is local education 1501 is
municipal
in their school budget proposed for the
coming year
they took out
increased funding to improve and expand
the CTE programs at Sugar River
vocational schools
that employers and Industry in that
municipality and the surrounding towns
asked for
that would benefit employment throughout
the area
Linda's comment about wealth brings in
wealth well poverty brings in poverty if
you can't create the training to create
the employees then you don't have
thriving business and the reason they
took those CTE programs out of the
budget is they're trying to preserve
a new teacher contract that's getting
voted on separately
that is structured to try hard to
improve teacher retention
in a district that has a long history
of employing
young inexperienced teachers and they
get experience in Claremont and then
they leave to get ten to twenty thousand
dollars more per year
almost anywhere else
so to me it's such a picture of what we
need to be addressing
and 529 I think really tries to do that
it's not perfect but it's a good step in
the right direction
thank you just another thing one of the
things that this school funding
commission focused on
when we looked at this two years ago
versus my kid
and if in fact we are concerned about
developing a Workforce
within this state
where businesses will come in as
following up with representative Damon's
comment
we need to be concerned about that if
I'm only concerned about my kids in
Hopkinton
it doesn't help the general population
within the state
to create a Workforce
so you take the you take the students
better in Claremont
those are just as important
as students in Rye
that have greater opportunity both from
their own family situation as well as
those who may not have the same kind of
situations in Claremont
and so for me
that Workforce across the state is
fundamental to funding schools
and that's why our report here that we
that we miss you it's called our schools
our kids
from that standpoint of trying to create
a a universe where children have an
equal educational opportunity and that's
why my focus is on our kids and not just
my children that are in Hopkinton
represent parenail
that report looks really interesting I'm
wondering if there's a way we can
receive a copy of that
yeah we we should have extra copies
a box on it all you have to do is read
well there's a lot of sections you need
to read in there
um you know there's some that I agreed
with and some I didn't agree with I was
on that at that study
um but my concern I do have a similar
concern as representative Miler just
spoke to
um it's hard for me to see things which
are going on the CTE Center in Salem in
Hudson
down other places and then I I see the
center that the kids from my town go to
April which happens to be in Vermont and
it's a CT Senate just does not have the
offerings
that other Centers do have yet it's it's
run by good people
it it just there is a difference in
obeyability of programs and I see some
other communities that are donor towns
right beside a town that's not a donor
town and the donor Town can't afford to
even have AP taught in their schools uh
whereas this this dual District abutting
it has that offerings because basically
the the wealth within the community
and that's a real picture throughout
this state
and and I I agree with a lot that's in
that report I didn't re regard support
part of the basic understandings of
where the dollars came from to do what
that report was trying to do
but I I I I see the need that we need to
address this and if we can help out with
this fiscal disparity and having that
sliding formula we developed in 709 and
something similar to that
um I think we need to start directing
the money to where it really is going to
have to get the biggest bang for the
buck and um and not negating what might
happen in your town representative
cardelli which is a town which has that
that wealth within it
um
but uh if we're going to want all this
Workforce that we need in the state
we're going to have to think how we're
going to achieve it representative
Cornell you know you want to rebut that
thank you just uh to point out that we
have some properties yeah with wealth we
have many
um and I can show you the run-down
trailers that do not
um so
um you know that's something to keep in
mind also we and we have a
um right at the average if not above
number of free and reduced students
yeah and and likewise with Sunapee which
I live in
um
that I was talking to superintendent the
free and reduced has gone up
tremendously uh since Coven in Sunapee
well the same thing in Bridgewater if
you're on the lake there
then you get off the lake on the other
side of the highway you you see the
opposite
so it's it's all over the state reps and
Lexus had her head over there for a
while
um thank you I wanted to ask rep Miller
you said that we value all children and
they're all important and just because
they live in this town as opposed to
that town doesn't make them any more or
less valuable and I'm wondering if you
also believe that a child just because a
public school doesn't work out well for
them and they need to go to
some other low facility design way of
doing education in order to work out do
they mean less or should we also be
making sure that we're funding children
as opposed to school buildings that's
sliding in a whole different decision
but that's a bill but those are bills
before but that's going into a different
discussion than the the the opposite
side whether I I'm there or not would
say well you better start funding the
public school more so they can compete
with what the the receiving school is
freezing that's the argument I believe
on the other side there's another
argument too so
um
yeah yeah one of the things we can
respond to that when we come to that
bill comes before us the other issue
that that really hasn't been talked
about much this morning and that is the
issue of property tax relief
uh and one of the things that the report
you'll see in there does talk about the
need for the state to really to to begin
to modify uh property tax relief for uh
low-income families uh when we looked at
the cert when we did our survey that
summer you recall Rick one of the things
we discovered is that it hadn't been
changed in 20 years
and so the the as the property values
have gone up and the property tax relief
has stayed the same
it wasn't much incentive for somebody to
go in and even provide the forms for Dra
to get that relief and one of the things
that we've been talking about here is
how do you also provide at the same time
you're dealing with with these formulas
how do you then deal with the issue of
Greater property tax relief for people
in your town Glenn that can that can't
afford that can get some relief and I
think that's another very important part
of this whole as you look at the whole
scheme here
we talked about that also you know the
veterans get a deduct of what 500 off
their bill
where if you're elderly it doesn't Cop
come off your bill it comes off of the
assessment on your property
and and so two different things there
that that we did consider on that
Commission on that committee
thank you so
I just wanna
no then please correct me if I don't
have this right
balancing features of 529
or communities like Sunapee and
representative cordelli's community
if you have a high incidence of pre and
reduced lunch
you will get
that part of additional Aid regardless
of your property values so you could
have high property values and not get
that part of the aid but it somewhat
balances out by providing Aid in two
am I making sense well you know if I can
if I can address that real quick you
know it's not about balancing out it's
about yeah it's about recognizing two
different things
um it's about recognizing
um uh taxpayer fairness and uh and
providing some relief where there's the
the least availability of Financial
Resources into a community
um as both the blanket relief it directs
it to where the re where the resources
are lacking so that's the fiscal
capacity disparity Aid part and then
there's the free and reduced price lunch
Grant
um which recognizes the fact that
whether you whether whether you're the
Manchester School District or the um or
the um
um you know or the Hopkins school
district or or the governor Wentworth
School District that that when you've
got higher percentages of students that
come from low income basketball
backgrounds your cost of education for
everybody increases and so so it's it's
providing relief both in a way that's
fair for students
through that in a way that's fair for
taxpayers and that's why the two the two
the two you know portions of this and um
and and and then I think what uh what
what Mel brought up with respect to a
directed low and moderate income
property tax relief program there have
been some changes to incremental changes
to that over the last I think two
sessions uh it's been incremental
there's another bill House Bill 569
which was heard in Ways and Means
yesterday I haven't caught up on it
since then but but uh but that actually
um revamps the low and moderate uh
property tax relief program and um and
and that I think is absolutely specific
to what representative cordelli was
saying that that not everybody lives in
in Wolfeboro and Tuftonboro are are rich
and that's true at every you know you
know every every place around the state
and um and and that's why that that
program is so important and it's really
the the uh you know an important you
know the third the third rung on this on
this stool of of providing um you know
taxpayer Equity student equity and and
targeted property directed property tax
relief
can we just take a break from this for a
sec because we have several other bills
and I got Mark here in front of us and
uh Mark we were discussing about the how
special education differentiated Aid
would work with this and I see Brian's
back there and he's been doing a little
work and we're running out of time here
for this work session
um so could you please explain you know
what kind of percentages you're looking
at in terms of which qualify for various
categories of
of increased differentiated Aid
this this will be related to I think the
last bill there 540.
Brian might have to run some run some
formulas real quick but um he's been
playing around with some data uh it's
based on a 2021 snapshot of the
different type of IEPs or sped programs
being offered in this in in the district
public schools and he's been trying to
bring that data up to Modern data
um so it's been it's been a little bit
of uh workarounds with the data to get
it to something that we can provide you
with some decent information but Brian
will run through some of those numbers
that he's been analyzing
thank you uh my name is bryony in
Department of Education Office of school
of Finance so like Mark mentioned we
took a 2021 snapshot so school year 2022
of special education students
um and we scaled that to
um
the actual ADM for that school year so
it's a little inflated a little bit just
to compare as much as we can Apples to
Apples uh so this bill would categorize
its abilities in categories a through C
found that with that
um
scaled number it would be about 22 000
almost 23 000 members within uh
disability category a
um about seven thousand in category B
and about 600 in category C so a
membership of about thirty thousand uh
which is comparable to school year 2022
just to kind of compare apples to apples
as best we can
that total Aid would come to would have
come to uh 83 million 83.7 million and
under
what was current law uh that was and
that would bring the total funding to
982 million
while the under that current law would
have been 962 million so about a little
under 20 million dollar increase uh
utilizing the categorized methodology
for especially so you're basically
saying it would take it up to about 83.7
from 60
three
yes yeah that sounds right yep okay
so it's an increase of 20 million
um so going back then for folks here in
the committee we we had approximately
rounding off 30 000 special education
students in the state with IEPs
and category a was for students which
are receiving support for less than 80
percent of the time and that is
according to the data that I had from
doe earlier was at 26.8 000 they're
saying 23 000 right there now and
category B would be for those that are
more than 80 percent uh which we had
identified initially at 2.7 000 now it's
seven thousand and the last category
which is catastrophic Aid residential
placement Hospital succession would be
600 we had approximately 760 758
something like that 600 600 yeah so okay
that clarifies that so we're looking now
rather than an increase of 10 million
dollars we're looking at an increase
around 20 million dollars that's our
best estimate without having actual
numbers it's hard that's basically what
we've tried to do our best to scale and
assign I know students with the Special
Education data those categories so
that's our best estimate at this time
yeah we'll work with if this bill ends
up over in finance we'll work to
fine-tune that number and give an
official uh analysis but representative
lad's analysis was using all their data
and the data shipped a little bit to
move from category a to the uh more
expensive categories so it's going to be
higher than the estimate representative
Vlad had but we will fine tune that
number with finance and get them a more
accurate number as the session
progresses if this bill progresses
foreign
any further questions on that
oh representative thanks very much Rick
so
um
so and this is a question to you Rick so
we we're also looking at uh House Bill
577 which is the category special
education categorical Aid and that 1.5
times 3.3.5 times and um and how does
um move along with with with that
540 has been designed as as part of
adequacy
whereas the catastrophic Aid is not or
special education Aid is not adequacy
what 540 that's appropriation it
basically says yes uh we are going to
wait these categories and we know the
weight that we're going to give to those
that are home in the hospital or
residential placement is going to have
to be more and that should be in
differentiated Aid well and across the
board available to every school district
that has a youngster in that category
whereas the catastrophic Aid is the the
I guess the more of the elephant in the
room now
um that we're going to have to decide
how do we tweak that if we're going to
tweak it do we go from
three and a half times before things
start clicking in down to one and a half
then we're we're the other that the
difference is going to have to be paid
for somewhere and it involves probably
more kids in that equation as well
and or do we address as represent
Belcher said do we start addressing the
upper portions of that and tweaking the
20 80 percent category and or it will
shrink down 100 category to less than
you know then we not 10 times maybe
eight times or six times I I think we
have to address that whole formula
seeing that this is a huge huge problem
in the state right now especially that
this shows up and it's based on the
previous year and you don't have the
money in the pot
um where do you get it
so
I I I can't answer that anymore yeah
yeah yeah yeah but I think it would be
so valuable to to you know see
you know how these how these two things
sort of meld you know together uh
because obviously they're you know one
of them's out of see one of them's
agreeing so they're they're they're
they're they're they're sort of two
different species here but um but
they're both they're both going after a
a similar
a
related problem
it's it's a really a policy issue too
from the standpoint
so I as a school district going to have
to find that dollar and I'm going to
look in my other operational capacity
areas in my budget to try to find the
dollars to support this extraordinary
need and then I'll call it an
extraordinary I I didn't anticipate it
it just moved into town so I got to pay
for this so I'm gonna have to subtract
from the PE program or something else to
make that or else I'm going to have to
have appropriate more time money and the
town's not going like that
um to incur more debt they're not like
that
um
yeah Mr chair would you would you define
for the committee the difference between
how much time we have here we have well
I mean the adequacy you have the base
adequacy the base amount that every
student in the state receives
and then you have these four areas in
differentiated a because we recognize
there are students in this first area
that have these special needs be it
English language learner be it
Remediation in a third grade reading
that if you don't qualify for all or
free and reduced or special education
qualifying that is part of what we have
done in reaction to Claremont one two
and a million and and and Londonderry
it's all there that's what we have to do
for every child in the state
then we have the grant programs on top
of that which we've been talking about
earlier today or where we try to help
those with the physical capacity
disparity Aid and extraordinary needs
Grant and the relief Grant that's on top
of though and that's nothing that's part
uh so the difference between our grant
programs if they're all done on a
reimbursement basement adequacy kind of
is a reimbursement basement and since
that you provided student data from the
year before we pay you based on that
data and based on a formula
um in the next year but with the with
our federal programming and grants with
our sped uh Aid it's really a one-to-one
you paid a particular cost you are
showing evidence that you paid that
particular cost and you're receiving
money to match that particular cost and
that Grant is restricted to compensate
you for that very specific cost that you
provided evidence to with adequacy it's
data and then data runs through the
formula and it delivers what it delivers
based on the formula and based on the
data and it's so but adequacy is also
unrestricted um so it's not designed to
reimburse for a specific cost it's
designed to kind of underwrite the
funding of your community using State
dollars and it has a constitutional
connection where sped Aid doesn't have
further
questions today we're going to call it
quits here because we have some other
things coming up here
so um if if a school doesn't have the
funding to to match then they don't get
the reimbursement in these grants
if they don't provide the service which
is potentially other legal problems they
could have but if they don't provide the
service uh
then then they're not going to get
reimbursed if they don't have the
funding that is a cash flow
appropriation challenge that they're
going to run into
um and and how they do that they could
run a deficit in their general fund and
then reimburse their General if they
have the cash to run a deficit if they
can afford it to run a deficit and not
you know run not start skipping their
vendors but if they can run a deficit in
communities can run a deficit if they
have the cash to do so they could
compensate their general fund
retroactively using State money I don't
know how districts do it I can get it
can get very complicated if they don't
have money uh they probably get a little
creative hopefully it all stays legal
um but yeah uh that's a particular
challenge but they can they can work
around that and use existing Authority
and laws to to figure that out but yeah
it's certainly not easy
well thank you very much I really
appreciate your taking the time for us
today
and uh we're gonna have to we've got a
lot of policy decisions ahead of us here
and we're going to start making some of
those when we start executing these
bills here so thank you very much we're
the amendment she's got it oh okay so
you can give that give give that to us
and we will we will deal because we're
gonna have to have a discussion
ourselves but I think we need to take a
little short break here uh folks been
sitting here for a long time
um
so thank you very much everybody we're
going to take a break here and start
so we're going to take an hour break now
have our lunch and come back and start
this up rather than at uh one we'll
start at 12 30. you know Republicans
here and there will be a republican
caucus launch right here in this room
we're not going to bring lunch for you
right so you better you better stay in
that party then because
it's not going to happen on this side of
the coin
we do not want to raise our property tax
okay
and and
um
represent Tanner if you can find that
Amendment
foreign
about which number we use
whether we go with the number for the
national eating disorder
which is a number not the same as 988
and so I'd like to have this discussion
just Orient around that particular which
number is used
are not used
and so we can just have a little bit of
a discussion here and then go on and and
address the bill
represent cordelli
thank you Mr chairman
um one of the issues I think that was
raised during the hearing I followed up
and on and got the information from
their website as to availability of the
hotline online chat is available Monday
through Thursday nine to nine and Friday
nine to five
for telephone calls at their 800 number
it's Monday through Thursday 11 A.M to 9
p.m and Friday 11 A.M to 5 p.m and text
it is available Monday through Thursday
3 P.M to 6 p.m and Friday 1 pm to 5 p.m
um I think that is an issue that needs
to be considered
represent Tanner
first of all I'd like to say that I
don't think this is an either or
uh issue
um that you can have the the crisis
hotline number and the Eating Disorders
number uh that's my first point and my
second point is that Eating Disorders
have a special
um
special kind of Crisis point to it that
and the special language to it and
that's quite different than
um suicide or the other crisis that may
come into the 988 number
um and the Eating Disorders hotline I
think is a is a group that's that's
been started and is in
um
in a period of actually growing because
the the crisis is growing along with
um covid and the increase in mental
health issues but this is a very
specific mental health issue with a very
specific need and like I said this isn't
a choice of one or the other both of
them could be included thank you
I have two questions which hopefully
somebody can answer
um one is the 98 is 988
um
do they do they if you call with a house
eating disorder do they then transmute
for you to one of those people who would
have the proper language
Etc and the other question is
if you're a kid who finally got the
nerve
to call and there's no answer on the
other end
is that going to make things better or
worse
that's this is for the whole committees
people can respond to that
representative dry
thank you it's my understanding 988
because it expanded from
um a suicide hotline to a mental health
one is equipped to refer you to whatever
you need both geographically and by
subject
foreign
that you say it's an eating disorder
that this would be the number they would
put you to of course if that would be a
time that that number would be
operational
representative
the thing the channel I I understand uh
Governor Lucas's concern of the double
number in a youngster or a student or a
young adult that anyway actually who
just uh I get the nerve up to make the
call but again if you get the nerve up
you can be able to that's a stop in the
right direction uh and the time frame is
as representative cordelli said and
represent wrong mentioned before uh is
limited but it's expanding
um so to have both numbers on the card I
think is is much more reasonable for a
student uh than it is for for uh just
having one it automatically getting the
wrong one so at least you have a default
piece there if you only put one you
don't have a default
um so I would be supporting putting both
of them on remember for a lot of the
people who use this we're going to use a
line these are high school age students
for the most part and body image is a
huge thing it's happening now School
issues all the time so clearly the the
data is there that they need something
and this is just one more tool in My
Mind One More tool for our students in
New Hampshire to be able to have an
access point that they didn't have
before and I think it's uh I think we
should should not negate the bill or
either or that's just me thank you
representative Damon
I concur with the it's not either or I'd
like to remind the committee of the
discussion and the hearing
about the usefulness of the info on the
ID card for people to simply be aware
whether it's that person who calls or
their friend that a helpline exists and
that help is available
I think we can have reasonable
confidence that the helpline hours will
expand and also the hours overlap with
the times when the people most in need
are likely to use it late afternoon
early evening are crisis times
um and
Eating Disorders are epidemic they're
they're often invisible to people who
don't know but there's a huge need I
think we'd be irresponsible not to pass
this
further represent Cornell
thank you I think 988 will refer you to
the Eating Disorders hotline but that
doesn't solve that they if they refer
you they still won't be open except for
those hours and I don't think we should
if we can keep people from calling at
988 unless it's an immediate crisis we
should because they're very busy and and
it would be helpful not to be tying up
the line with calls that could be going
someplace else
so and and they will refer to the to the
Eating Disorders hotline which won't be
represent cordelli
thank you uh I remember several terms
ago it might be three I had a bill
um to require the poster be hung in each
school for the sex abuse hotline
um we spent an hour at least talking
about the size and material for that
poster
um I'm wondering
should it be a hotline number on the ID
card in sex abuse hotline what
are we going to have maybe a priority
list of hotlines to put on the ID cards
for the representative uh dry and then
representative Belcher
thank you Mr Sharon um we thought due
respect especially to the the wonderful
people we had come speak to this the
trend in emergency medicine is to move
to the simpler numbers that's why I went
from 9-1-1 for emergency calls 988 for
suicide and now expanded
Suds and and just about anything else
you will have
professionals answering that call and
they made it nationwide this year
because they have the capacity to handle
this it will be sent to the right place
geographically and if this number is not
working at the national hotline then
they will have another place to send you
if you go to the this hotline and it's
not working I don't know where it will
send you I'm going to say that we would
be bucking a trend that towards the
simplification of universal numbers and
National numbers if we stick all these
10 digit numbers on an ID card
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and the follow-up on
the last two comments we've heard I just
want to also say that again we do need
to be cognizant of how much information
we're putting on these cards I think if
I remember correctly the cdsd statistics
from uh from one of the last uh surveys
that included information on on teenage
suicides suggested that
something like 40 of our young people
have considered seriously considered
suicide within the last 30 days that is
one of the biggest things we are facing
right now and I would hate to even
possibly see anything detract from that
number or from possibly going to a
representative Tanner
thank you
I think when you have a universal number
just like you have a dispatch number
there's a delay between
using that number and then the referral
particularly if it isn't for a crisis
situation like an immediate situation
that's like suicide or maybe overdose
that sort of thing
Eating Disorders is a special category I
mean I I just can't
I guess I can't convince people who
haven't had the experience of dealing
with people that have had eating
disorders
but it's a it's a whole different ball
game it's a different ball game than uh
depression you it's it's a different
ball game than drug addiction
um it's a different ball game than than
uh accidents and first aid and uh EMT
work
um it's very specific and if it isn't
handled correctly right at the beginning
of the of the interaction with the
person
if they're not knowledgeable you know
things can go south really fast and
um and the person will just either hang
up or or take it even as more of a
indication that what they're doing uh to
themselves is either good or you know
that they that it they internalize it I
guess I I I'll put it that way so it's
it's really important and both these
numbers can be called or text
um I think that
um you know if you want a garden variety
of of phone numbers to call
um you know I don't think that's going
to happen because as as representative
dryers said at least for a lot of the
crisis things where you you have like a
dispatcher who can immediately go and
defuse the situation and send out the
emergency uh or get the person contacted
with somebody that's an emergency
um you know that's being Consolidated
but this this is a it's a big issue I
mean it's a big issue and it probably
kills more people more teenagers
um in the long run and and if it doesn't
kill them
there's a there's a woman on my road
that is um she must be she must be in
her 60s or yeah I'd say 50s or 60s right
now
she is now at um a residential
situation uh but it's one where they can
they can leave and it doesn't I bet you
on Friday when we get 10 below she'll
still be walking the road and her her
face her body is so distorted
um it's unbelievable she's anti-social
as far as being able to deal with other
people because of her physical Outlook
now
um and yet she can't drop the the the
repetitive exercise to keep her you know
just Skin and Bones I mean it's it's
really
um just a horrible situation and she's
been dealing with it like I said for 50
or 60 years she comes from a family that
I know that has all the resources in the
world
um and she she just hasn't been able to
beat it so
um I guess I I and the fact that the
young man that came and talked to us the
other day I mean just the fact that he
was he didn't go to 988 he went to the
he went to his Google and he looked up
eating disorders and he got the Eating
Disorders number
Okay so
he's just one example of what kids do
and
um so I guess
I I've given it my best but I really
think this is something that needs to be
very special and very much on their ID
card thank you okay thank you we've had
you know more than five minutes here you
know five or ten minutes of discussion
here what I'm going to do is call a
brief caucus
and then we're going to be back here in
about five minutes so Republicans will
meet in this room right here and we'll
chairman uh I move that we
approves this bill as presented it's
addresses a national no no just
OTP or itl or retain one of the other
OTP I'll second it
so we have a motion on the table Madam
one is to name the bill
presented it
like
okay
um so I'm just going to just say we got
the bill on the floor right now is there
any further discussion I'll recognize
you for that representative
so we have the bill on the table right
now representative uh uh Ford made the
motion I second it OTP representative
um
oh sorry so the first
um Amendment takes the uh just two of
I'm passing the they each have a number
did you get focus on going that way
yeah
there should be five extra
would you like me to start or not
chairman okay I would assume that uh 108
is what you were discussing
um I'd like to just yes well I'd like to
discuss zero zero two zero H the first
bill which was
um after our meeting we took the
took the higher ed out of the bill
um that that's the main change in this
one
um so that's that's why I have that
particular
um
Amendment okay the Second Amendment
0108h is uh an amendment to add that
this bill will be known as the Matthew
Brown act and he was the young man that
came and presented it to the committee
sure so I'd like to put forth the uh
Amendment zero zero two zero h
just um after talking to you know the
people at the higher education although
I think they need the the number they
were saying how their card is actually a
card that has entry it's an entry key
and also there uh you know has a lot of
other things with it so that's why it
foreign
like
Vice chairman cordelli no
yes
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal
yes representative cortielo yes
representative Myler yeah representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative Fox yes
representative Damon yes representative
represent Tanner are you please put
forth your other Amendment thank you Mr
chair
um
Amendment
0108 h
uh this amendment um I'd like to put
forward that uh says that the actual now
be known as the Matthew Brown Act
okay second on that yes okay
any discussion on the amendment to call
this the Matthew Brown Act
yes just
um I thought he was A Brave Young Man
and deserves this
represent McDonald I agree that he was a
very courageous for coming to testify
but has anyone contacted him to ask if
he would like this we wouldn't want to
maybe good point very good point
Mr chairman he has been contacted and I
hope if it goes to the house floor which
uh should that he'll be able to come in
the gallery and and have it
and see it come before the house
and and he is willing to it's both he
and his family have been contacted and
they're willing to do this
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble
yes representative pedernal yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yeah representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes
representative Drew uh Drew Fox I'm
sorry yes it's a little confusing uh
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes 20 years
zero Nays
Mr chair yes uh could we not put this on
consent so that he can be recognized
from the floor we're going to not to
pass as amended now and Jennifer 4 we
have two amendments here when we
take this over to Olas will they
consolidate this into one Amendment
people have to do
um
amendment number and that new amendment
number is what we see in the calendar
yes okay so that's sop
good that's the way we've operated
before so what we're going to do is
we're going to prove uh the bill as
amended by both of these numbered
amendments and then we will later in the
calendar see a different amendment
number which is incorporating the two
that we took care of here it's saving us
from having to go over and get something
written right now
everybody got that
Okay so
we have a
we've amended
um this bill twice so we now have on the
table
to approve
uh House Bill 35
with the two amendments so it'd be
octopaths as amended with the two
amendments that we've just gone through
and recommended that be part of that any
questions on what we're doing we're
going to make the motion
yeah so
um
let's see who who uh reps represent Ford
would you make that motion place and
represent Tanner would you second it
please
I recommend lock to pass on the bill
yes
has it been thank you and I second the
Bill thank you very much Madam clerkley
foreign
cordelli no
Representative leckis no
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher no
representative dry no
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
Representative pedernal no
Representative cortiello no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner
yes
representative luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes
representative Fox yes
representative Damon yes
um can we can you add those up again
please
how many people
well go go ahead and just add them up
please
represent you know that's modern math
yeah
pardon me
we normally don't do this commenting we
have a lot to go so at the end of the
okay the final vote on that is octopass
has amended 15 to 5.
and we're closing that uh exact session
we're going into the next one which is
HB 45 uh this deals with uh loan
forgiveness
yes
it would be a committee Amendment
because it's you know the majority has
approved both and that's what we want a
committee Amendment not amendments in
anybody's name so so when you combine
them that's what we normally do is make
it a committee on Monday
no that won't get the wrong one color
no I reported myself
what do we do about this go over the
Nays
represented Belcher represented dry
representative pedernal and myself and
cordelli and cordelli I'm sorry I must
have misheard you okay duly noted it's
through the calculator
I'm a words person remember that
excuse me I I recognize representative
okay let's get into the uh opening up HP
foreign
establishes a committee to study student
loan forgiveness in New Hampshire
and I recognize representative McDonald
for a motion
thank you I move that we find House Bill
45 and expedient to legislate is there a
second
second a second
Professor McDonald do you care to speak
to your motion
I believe that this bill is finding a
study committee that is unnecessary as
there are other movements currently
throughout the country to study this
issue thank you you're welcome
representative cordelli
uh just that um we have I think a
committee to look at uh eliminating
committees uh so I don't think we need
another committee
um at this point
further discussion
I'd like to add a couple words in there
the when we look at committee membership
you see three members of the house and
three members of the Senate
I doubt very seriously the Senate would
ever put three members up and in the
quite frankly we're oftentimes lucky to
get one member serving from the Senate
um uh and I think most people recognize
that yes represent Tanner well I totally
agree with you and that's probably you
know what I'm looking at the bill as I
also realize that that student loans are
one of the major things in New Hampshire
we have the highest student loan debt in
the nation and
um I think while other people are
studying it
um that New Hampshire needs to address
this problem the funding for higher
education oh I I agree on that
absolutely in fact we may have the
highest
maybe second of Vermont but the highest
student loan debt but our students in
New Hampshire
do not default on their student debt
they pay it off whereas in other states
it's contrary so we do have a problem
with the cost of Education in the state
further discussion
represent Damon
I acknowledge what has been said and
that New Hampshire students do pay back
their debt but a considerable
compromising cost in their lives going
forward
and I think this is a very serious local
issue and we're doing a disservice to
our students and our communities to not
address it
period
represent pedernal
having recently gone through several
FAFSA applications on my own I know that
students entering College have to go
through an extensive educational
training on what will be entailed and
taking on these loans and they have the
option to click yes or no and they fully
take that on if they have actually done
the videos and their parents haven't
been the ones doing them for them they
should enter this agreement knowing full
well what they will be encountering
after they graduate from college
further discussion
Professor Belcher thank you Mr chair
just briefly the concept of of
forgiveness of a loan brings the mind
the idea that there was something
predatory done to these students and and
to a certain extent I think there's
something true there there is something
true
but the entity responsible for being
predatory to these students was not the
taxpayer if anybody is responsible it
was certain colleges and universities
who brought students in the programs
knowing well that they wouldn't be able
to repay easily the loans they're taking
out which is why I would be generally in
opposition to this unless it was
specifically oriented toward looking at
the one predatory party and bringing
these students in which is the
endowments of universities
and I'd like to add into that last year
we passed under adequacy personal
finance literacy
and it's it can be attached to the
economics courses were taught in high
school I think it's incumbent upon us as
Educators in the in the high school
level to really
teach students the the the
ramifications of taking on this type of
debt how to use your credit cards what a
savings account is
um what a budget is uh all that and
that's one of the reasons why we had the
New Hampshire Bankers Association coming
in so vehemently and pushing that bill
last year and now it is part of our
adequacy personal finance literacy is
important and I do agree that student
loan forgiveness is a critical issue
along with our teacher shortage which we
have in the state and and many are
getting out because of that debt and the
what they're being paid as teachers
doesn't help them in paying off that
debt that's why you're also seeing many
teacher preparation programs in colleges
where the enrollment is declining
um yes represent my way
notwithstanding the responsibility that
one takes on
the reason why they take on this debt at
least in this state is because our
higher education is underfunded
and we forget that sometimes
and we have the highest
for those who are going to our state
schools particularly unh
we have the highest
Public School tuition in the country
and that's because this state does not
provide the kind of uh support for
higher education and those ultimately
hopefully will stay in the school stay
in the state and provide a sound economy
and so that's the concern that I have
about not looking at this bill is that
once again this legislature gets off
by not providing the kind of funding
that needs to be taken place with our
higher education institutions thank you
represent parano yes representative
Miler could you point to where in this
legislation IT addresses the
underfunding of our education
yes if I may respond the issue of
underfunding this school has been a long
tradition in this state and so kids who
are going to go to Pro our Public
Schools
they have to take out loans
we have we have places we I have friends
of mine who send their students their
children out of state and they pay out
of state tuition is cheaper than what
in-state tuition is here
so that's the concern that I have that
we we are not meeting our obligations
from a state to provide the appropriate
resources for higher education to keep
the tuition lower thank you and we're
going to save this and we'll have to
take a break go ahead representative
Balboni and then represent luno I'm just
getting back to the bill at hand the
bill isn't asking us to solve the
problem right now is just stating that
we should put together a committee to
represent Luna thank you very much Mr
chair
um you know I also think there's there's
a certain timely timeliness sorry to
um to to uh to household 45
uh and uh and you know setting up
establishing a committee to study
um uh student loan forgiveness and I
think in conjunction with some other
conversations that are going on uh
around the state right now surrounding
um you know a possible program called
New Hampshire promise uh much like what
they're doing in Vermont right now which
would provide
um basically the uh the the state would
guarantee for for Pell eligible students
enrolling in Community College the
difference in intuition between what
what Pell gives them and in the price
Community College we have um
we have I think maybe the highest price
uh Community College uh tuition in the
uh in the country but as I think many
most people know we've we've Frozen
tuition for the last
maybe decade and uh and over that period
of time the the Pell Grant amount has
has really has has approached within a
couple hundred dollars what uh what a
full what full-time
um uh full-time student tuition would be
at our community colleges so as we
consider things like New Hampshire
promise I think it's I think it's it's
it's certainly fair for us to uh to also
study student loan forgiveness and and
what may uh come out of that as as um as
as part of this effort thank you it
might be interesting to note that we do
have a higher education commission or
committee here in the legislature
already and there's no reason why the
issue of student debt student tuition
shouldn't be taken up by that particular
committee and it would be a stat it
wouldn't have to be stopped putting
another committee it's been both parties
put forth we have too many commissions
and too many committees and here we are
forming another one uh when we already
so
representative Woodcock thank you over
there chair uh just a question for you I
forgot you're on the education board
with New Hampshire ranked 49th or 50th
in funding of their state colleges you
know it bounces back and forth between
UVM and us
but UVM has a different way of looking
at their applications eighty percent of
their students come from out of state
where here it's down around 55 or so
percent
and so they are able to maintain
barely due to the result of what they're
taking from out of state students
they're becoming a semi-private school
if you're in Vermont elsewhere you're
going to go to Castleton or Northern
University of Vermont so
um comparing ourselves to we we're
there's no question we're right there so
so regardless of UVM in the country
we're either 49th or 50th we're at the
bottom one or two in the country of
funding public education
12-16 yes I know that okay now that's a
question that's all we are as a state
when we put this budget together and you
probably hear from them when the
governor presents it that we're putting
more into Capital Improvements for the
University system than we have in the
past and that's jumping up significantly
simply because we're trying to support
Granite guarantee which if you're if
you're a student in New Hampshire of a
certain property level you can go
tuition free to the university system
here in this state
so there's a lot more to this that we
need to discuss thank you yes represent
cordelli thank you uh the problem I see
with any of these student loan
forgiveness programs is
um we forgive uh student loans today
what happens in five years five years
we're going to do another loan
forgiveness program the real real
problem is the cost of college
um there you can read papers and studies
until the cows come home
um about that but we need to do
something about that
um this student loan forgiveness is just
a Band-Aid
person wake up it's the response a
committee might like this may have to
look into that issue rather than
this is not a unique problem just to New
Hampshire uh how many of us have
children that gone to school in other
states I have one that's uh
hurry up in her middle 40s still paying
off her master's program from University
of South Carolina Medics medical school
and Audiology still paying that debt so
yes representino
I I would also argue that just helping
students pay off their debt in the state
of New Hampshire or having attended our
University's New Hampshire University
schools
um doesn't guarantee that they will stay
in the state and that was what the
testimony was stating
yeah we exported a lot of college
students out of the state representative
Tanner
so um thank you I I got my teaching
degree
at the same time there was a teacher
shortage I mean we we go on these cycles
and one of the things that that they did
was if you taught in a school district
that was considered a high-risk District
or a district that had low property
values a certain point percentage of
your college loan was was forgiven and I
think those are the kinds of programs
that that really are needed we talked
about it with nurses and social workers
during the covid
um epidemic and and uh so I think
there's a lot of alternatives to loan
forgiveness rather than some some people
I think think it's just a carte blanche
you know write it off kind of thing but
there are different loan forgiveness
programs and we do have a teacher
shortage committee currently that exists
it's a Senate bill and we lost the
senator which was chair of that dude he
is not coming back so we need to put
another person in that place but this is
another topic which is being discussed
by that committee
how to maintain and keep our teachers in
okay before we're going to take any
action on this I'm going to wait for the
one member to come back
so we are at a break here
for about this for a few minutes pardon
me homes caucus and a few moments yes
please
45 it's a bill that's itl it deals with
uh loan forgiveness a committee
establishment to evaluate and assess
loan forgiveness
Vice chairman cordelli yes
yes
representative Ford
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Myler oh
representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison no
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative Fox
no
representative Damon
foreign
for those that are new to how we do this
you'll see sometimes on the calendar the
vote might be you know there's 18 people
on a committee and it might be seven two
five
it's just the others weren't there
that's all there's do you want to ask if
there's a minority
yeah we will do that
okay
um we're gonna jump down and I'm going
to try to address some of these early
bills I we got to get them out of
committee
so I'm going to start with the bottom
one that I have on my list it's 578 here
okay this bill establishes the position
of reporting administrator in the
Department of Education
HB 578 it is a finance bill and it is an
early bill that means we have to have it
out of committee by the 16th of the of
this month
emotion
oh yeah give I'm going to give the gavel
over to represent cordelli thank you
very much
um I would call on chairman lad for a
motion I I moved that this uh Bill b itl
was their second representative miler
discussion
yeah
um
typically we when we uh approve new
positions over at the Department of
Education we want to ensure that this a
position is in line with priorities of
the department the legislature and what
is going to be best in fact for our
students in our state
and when I look at the duties and
responsibilities of this particular bill
is to basically receive and coordinate
all these reports which come to into the
department one of those reports is you
got to hand in from the school districts
your policy on gifted talented education
we provide no money for gifted talented
education in the state we know there
might be policies on that but we don't
provide any you know funding for that
and districts may have that but that's
funded on their own recognizance so
um at this point in time I see that as a
position that's
um that that duty alone doesn't make it
with me secondly uh to look at the
accountability reports for the
extraordinary needs grip grants which we
provide that's approximately 14.2 or so
million dollars and we'll go on to nine
million dollars it's less and these are
reports that you've got to report as to
how you're using these monies that you
receive there's going to be a bill Ford
which we have which is going to move
that those monies be unrestricted and so
it would be no need for a report to Doe
other reports are the third grade
reading
there's a number of ways we're looking
at spending that limited amount of
dollars there that is also part third
grade reading is part of the
differentiate Aid within adequacy and
that funding is part of the adequate
formula which includes base adequacy in
the four components of differentiated
Aid and that money is given not given
but provided to districts to use it for
by the districts to attain and deliver
an adequate education it doesn't
specifically say You must use this for
um looking at some of the other
requirements is other reported
requirements established in law
so at this point in time my my I guess
the biggest concern is that we have a
lot of programs where we're looking at
funding uh areas which really have will
make a dramatic and change in
instructional curriculum in the in
schools building schools Etc I don't
think that this is a time we should be
putting money in a direction that is not
absolutely necessary or required so this
is why I put forth the itl motion
wow uh seen none
yes
yes oh I'm sorry
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford
representative Belcher no rep
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Myler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison representative Wilcox yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative
box yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
19 years zero Nays
representative woodcock's yes is still
is that what you told the kids out on
the uh in the hallways
consent
is it okay to put that on consent
anybody oppositional that consent thank
you
the amount of money on that is a
fraction of what we usually put things
in your calendar this is what 160 Grand
they're about so we'll put it in consent
okay the next bill which we're looking
at is HB 487 just working up my list
here uh from larger number to smaller
numbers on the early bills 487 is a bill
four eight seven
remember
okay I recognize representative for a
motion I move itl on House Bill 487.
is there a second
second represent Cornell he seconds it
represent Peril Do you have a
discussion
yes I am
although I am very impressed with the
pamphlet that was put out by nofa New
Hampshire explaining their situation I
think that after a morning of discussing
school funding it would be inappropriate
to take money from
the school system that's having trouble
funding its own students and invest that
money and and in turn invest that money
represent uh cordelli nothing further
further discussion
representative Tanner
thank you
uh coming from Sullivan County which is
a has a high agricultural Heritage to it
um
I think the more we can support our
local farms would be is is fantastic
this is a fairly simple program the
amount of money may seem like
astronomical but as we just said the 165
000 was not
um a big chunk concerned of what we
normally do here I actually have an
amendment from the sponsor for this bill
um I think it it's
the more children learn where food comes
from and good food comes from and and
the connection with the local farmers
and the uh influx of maybe a small
amount of money into the local economy
um would be great and so I don't see
this again as an either or that you're
taking money vital money away from local
schools I see it as promoting a program
promoting the local economy and
hopefully that local economy supports
the schools more thank you
further discussion represent perineal
are the schools in the business of
did you hear what she just said
oh okay I so heard somebody say what
question was going out and I thought
well maybe it's going out to the
committee and then I looked over here
and saw represent Allison I said did you
hear the question I thought he was
trying to respond so okay
your questions to you next one no but he
I think he had his didn't you have your
hand going up or anything like that
well see I thought you were going to
respond to the question
and then if I could make my comment
after that I'd appreciate it
uh I I think that that yeah I'm not sure
the local school district has a
responsibility for uh improving local
economies but I I I think it's a good
idea I don't think it's a responsibility
but it's a good idea that's the answer
of the question my comment is uh when we
heard testimony on this bill and we've
heard a lot of it over two years uh
there were any number of issues that
were raised one by the Commissioner of
Agriculture who suggested when he
testified that there aren't enough there
aren't enough producers of
meat and fruit and so on in the state to
provide sufficient amounts of money
sufficient amount of product to schools
and twelve hundred dollars per school I
don't see that as a problem I live right
next to an apple orchard which is 155
acres and they have apples available
with two Cold Storage year round any any
reason well when the junior high the
high school in Concord is going to use
up their 1200 on those apples fairly
quickly uh all you have to do is go to
the farmer's market in any one of these
areas but here in Concord uh we have a
winters Farmer Market there's three or
four producers of meat there uh that is
available year round uh I mean it's a
it's a small program in terms of the
scope of money that we're dealing with
and the bill is a win for communities
for families for kids for Farmers uh
frankly I'm I'm
puzzled that we we're dealing with uh
you know so many objections to to
something like this
thank you Mr chair you're welcome uh
represent dry
I like the idea of farm to school I
think we have a robust program here
already what I don't like is a hundred
and ninety five thousand dollars to do
another position and 50 000 of that
being for setting up a program which is
already in place in a number of schools
I also
um
and unwilling to commit to a long-term
funding of that position until we find
out if schools will actually jump on
board with that like you said one
thousand two hundred dollars that's the
maximum is not a lot even for a small
school uh and for I can't even imagine
for a large you know Union High School
that this would make it the worth the
trouble to go through uh that they
couldn't already uh do on their own I am
totally in favor of schools working with
Farms I'm totally in favor of making it
easy for the farms and schools to do
that I don't think that setting up an
extra person in
conquered to oversee the problem of the
further discussion representative Tanner
I have an amendment that that speaks to
some of the appropriation for this bill
but I do think that uh
the reason that I said that it's part of
the economy is that everything's tied
together when I talked about schools
before in poverty areas that it's a
vicious cycle that that industry doesn't
come that
um then people you know the property
values go down and it's just it it kind
of churns I think this is a way to
actually
to spin it just the opposite way you
have uh areas rural areas in in New
Hampshire
that really would Thrive I think on a on
something like this we have in our area
several Farms that have csas and we have
Farm stands all year round and
um north of us up in Margaret's areas
representative arise area there's milk
producers that that produce all kinds of
different meat products as well as milk
products and I just think this is a
nudge a nudge to get schools involved
um and they it's a it's an enabling bill
it's opt-in it's not required that
everybody
performs in it and I think it would be
such a big Boon to the area and and to
our counties thank you
represent uh yes representative
I just wanted to point out that online
six one of one of the things that I
object to is that it says
only school districts participating in
the national school lunch program shall
be eligible for reimbursement because I
feel this discriminates against schools
not participating in the federal lunch
program so I just wanted to bring that
up
I don't know if anyone wants to comment
representative Ellison I'll comment on
that uh we're this is tied into some
other legislation coming before us on
breakfast and luncheon who participates
at this point we can only find one
school district in the state that
doesn't participate in the Federal
program so I think your point is well
taken but we're talking about one school
district
yes representative parent now there's
lots of conversation about how in
certain counties there's an abundance of
farming and an abundance of food that
would Supply these schools however in my
town of wolfborough we have a farmer's
market every summer and part of the time
during the winter and they have a very
hard time finding local farmers in fact
one of the arguments is that there are
several producers from Maine who come
over and they have the abundance of the
produce at our farmers market so not all
further discussion representative
woodcock
thank you chairman
um I would I would recognize that uh
representative is accurate down in
Wolfeboro to have a lot of looking on
besides farming
um but this is for the entire State of
New Hampshire any product bought grown
in New Hampshire Fitness after Carol
come from Carroll County in Northern
Carroll County we happen to have quite a
few Farmers I'd be happy to participate
in this on the New Hampshire side I I
can't find any reason why we would be
objecting to providing New Hampshire
Farmers provide New Hampshire food to
New Hampshire schools uh in this state
and just keep the cycle of helping it's
all like a Career Education move but
it's also great for the school system
and for the farmers thank you the farm
is a struggling yeah represent Hall
thank you for taking my question uh
actually another question the statement
actually
um in terms of okay I just had a brain
crap
oh my God wait
um
oh I know I was gonna say yeah so we
talk about the farmers we're talking
about the communities let's talk about
what the kids are eating if the kids get
this food it's a win-win thank you
profession Damon
thank you
um echoing representative Paul it's
about the kids you need to be fed in
order to have your maximum cognitive
function and you need to be fed well
I think this program will help children
eat more of the good foods that are
produced locally also Growers will grow
to demand in other words if a school
system contracts with a farm I will buy
your green beans as long as they you
have them through September into October
they'll grow more of that crop so that's
another version of availability and
making it good for their economy and
therefore good for the broader Community
um and I neglected to say this the other
day there's less food waste when food
is delivered from local production and
consumed locally and we have a major
food waste problem in this country so
it's a side benefit of this bill which I
vigorously support and frankly thought
when I originally read it that it was a
represent dry
thank you Mr chairman there's nothing in
this bill that prohibits any school from
buying from any local Farm the maximum
is one thousand two hundred dollars for
our school over the year that in a
school budget of 7 million is
kittens this is not to make money for
the Farms or the schools it's to to
nudge maybe but I think that we can
nudge without spending for another
person in Concord and another 50
000 for it
represent cardelli
thank you I believe there's already a
form to classroom program in the state
that seems quite active I think that
that's the better vehicle for
instructing our students on where their
food comes from then this program
Vegas for represent leckers
that was a good point because that's not
in this bill I mean the instruction
isn't part of this but I did talk to my
local Farm
um who has tried numerous years the high
school and the farm have tried to work
out something that would work but what
he said is I just can't produce things
far enough into the season that it makes
sense to have anything ongoing but
um and I like the idea of farms and
schools trying to work things out I
think that's great my concern is that
in putting this program in that gives
schools a little bit of money to
incentivize them we're spending a whole
lot of money and the school will be
spending a whole lot of money to follow
the rules right to track this is this
really coming locally is this what you
know all that paperwork that gets
generated whenever we start a program as
opposed to just the school and the local
Farm working together and doing this
without all this intervening another
person at the doe another report that
has to be done money trying to go back
and forth for a a small amount of money
it may cause some of the smaller schools
more than that in somebody to track and
do the paper you know all that stuff it
it's much better just left to the school
than the local farms
to come up with something with works
with them without having to put in all
this governmental oversight and and
bureaucracy and all that other stuff
that makes it inefficient
representative thank you
um on the nofa New Hampshire dot org
website
um an underneath Farm to school in New
Hampshire it says that 149 schools in
New Hampshire are participating in farm
to school programming
76.5 percent serve local food 73.5
percent provide food nutrition or
agricultural education 55 percent of
those schools have edible Gardens and
nearly 50 percent hold student field
trips to Farms taste tests and cooking
demos I would argue that there is
already a robust Farm to school program
um I haven't mentioned anything and I
I've mentioned every time we come up
with a farm what is the definition of
local production what is the definition
of local food
um and you know where I live right in
the Connecticut River
and four corners Farm is right across
the river which has a lot of surplus
crops which they provide to
um schools they also sell some that have
a cheaper rate to Hannaford Brothers
um we also have PT Farms which is one of
the two slaughterhouses in the state
which uh the beef that are slaughtered
come from Vermont as well uh is that
going to be considered local is that a
pro or a product that originates and how
do we differentiate between the meat
that's in that uh Farm in their farm
store between that and New Hampshire and
that of Vermont
um and the other concern I have
is Echoes what the we have heard from
the Department of Agriculture here in
marketing foods and marketing is that
what is sustainable and and are we small
such a small state that we can't sustain
and should we have a better definition
of what local is is local not just New
Hampshire but also Vermont in our our
Maine or Massachusetts
um and even I've I spoken with the
commission over there and for us to
truly get involved with something we'd
probably have to have a wider scope of
region which includes Pennsylvania and
New York
um and I'm not a farmer and I'm not in
that business so I really can't comment
too much on it but I am concerned that
even when I chaired the select board for
years up in Haverhill
we gave a local buy or a local right to
those towns which abutted us when we
were looking for contracted Services
we'd give them a first priority before
we started looking afar so we could keep
employment and by that any town that
abutted us on the other side of the
river was also considered local
so we are our community that um you'll
see just as many green plates where I
live this will the old man the mountain
and and so
um
I I have a tough time understanding why
we are getting so local that local is
only in New Hampshire
um
this state is so small that we can't
we're we're a region so I think we've
got to expand upon that and get a better
definition of and it says right here
originate in New Hampshire
um
I might take that different ways
you know it where's it where where's it
packaged
um a lot of our milk goes out and it
goes out to the co-ops in the New York
State Booth brothers and comes back to
us both brothers being owned by Hood
so there's much to this that I would
like to see some further definition and
understanding before I can support
something which is not going to really
be a benefit to the region I live in
okay we're gonna have to slow down again
because we have a member that's
testifying upstairs
and we just run try and get him
so we'll take a short break if you need
to get up and walk or stretch please do
so
foreign
it's too bad that we couldn't get my
questions are what is originated
solution if it could be defined better
in the bill I don't support something
see so bye
good Amendment so maybe if there's a
minute
I got the USA grant for the local food
purchase assistance program their
definition of multiple words 400 mile
radius applies to this but that's not
what this bill says
originate in New Hampshire but if they
did something with the USDA definition
today
yeah yeah that would help you can get a
couple people to come along I don't know
I I don't dare you to speak on behalf
somebody else but it would certainly
make a difference yeah if there's any
questions
on our side are not owned by New
Hampshire
as long as the farmers get paid and the
[Music]
yeah and that's right we have Wendy Rich
which is not Ducks apples up well we are
in the New Hampshire side in Haverhill
but on the other side is where um most
why why are you gonna label it just
perhaps
yeah
[Music]
according to the USDA and if you made
so would you have to support
um
our
school is on both sides of the river
um and and our buses around it says
Haverhill Cooperative on it and then
also lists the Vermont schools which and
we run the same routes
so that we save money we save half a
million dollars annually just by sharing
Roots yep so it's um
I guess that's where I am anybody that
tries to that's an old culture we're not
going to change it
we're on this side of the state you're
on that side of the state where
everybody should work together
everybody's in one community and I think
the USC gets that the community is a
radius
probably the best way to do it is the
um
is itl
for HB 445 which is 37 excuse me 47
excuse me 487 dealing with the farm to
chairman cordelli Vice chairman Cordell
Excuse me yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald
yes representative Noble yes
representative Peter now yes
representative course yellow yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Ellison oh representative
Wilcox you representative Hall Nell
representative Balboni no representative
10 years 10 years
so the motion fails Jefferson Tanner I'd
like to make a motion ought to pass
is there a second I'll second
have an amendment yeah represent Myler
made the second uh representative Tanner
yeah well you've already supported
representative Tanner uh do you have any
discussion uh not more than I already
have as I was told no
um I just think this is an important
bill and I'm willing to push it a little
bit so okay
are there any amendments for this bill
yes there are Amendment zero one zero
for the record
it's saying it is Rip Santana you like
to
yes this this amendment uh was put
forward uh from the bill sponsor uh
representative Simpson and um it was to
address some of the issues that were
talked about uh in our previous when we
had testimony when she testified and as
you see it changes some of the fiscal
note for it
um we're also uh discussing uh having a
floor Amendment if this goes through uh
to increase the range
um out of New Hampshire to the what the
USDA has which is 400 miles radius of
the school
um
so we're trying to make some amendments
to make this bill a little bit more
palatable and and uh hope for bipartisan
support for the farmers and so are you
making a motion to OTP the
10103h I am uh yes okay is that second
yeah
okay we have a motion to uh approve zero
one zero three h which is an amendment
to
we've had some discussion on that so is
there any further discussion on this
amendment
Vice chairman cordelli no
we're not in the discussion mode we're
no
representative Ford
no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
representative core to Yellow no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell representative
Tanner yes representative luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative
Fox yes
representative Damon yes
chairman lad no
10 years and 10 Nays
okay we need uh we're back now to the
original motion that we had which is
this is now on the bill as it was
introduced
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
Representative cordelli no
representative leckis no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative pedernal no
Representative no representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative Fox yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
10 years 10 days
so the end result in this one folks is
it's going to go
um to the floor with no recommendation
there's going to be two reports and when
we get to the floor the positive vote
motion will come first that is ought to
pass
theater
are you looking who moved and seconded I
got lost there that was second by
was Tanner and Myler
okay
okay we're going on to the next bill
right now it's another early bill it's
deals with EFA
and applications I got an abbreviated
definition there
um
we're gonna have to get the people that
uh that do our work for us in printing
and stuff they're doing thicker paper
starting rip every time you're turning
the page you have to allow the all these
things start falling apart
um
we need more paper that's right local
paper
and produced in the state okay relative
to applications for Education Freedom
accounts program this is HP 430 FN and
do we have a
motion here from Mr Cardell
representative cardelli now you do and
he's like yeah
is there a second
represented leica's seconds the 430
motion of itl uh would you like to speak
to your motion representative cordelli
uh thank you Mr chair
um this uh legislation would require
a
applicant to the education Freedom
account program to have spent uh a year
currently a year in New Hampshire public
school before applying or uh likewise if
they are entering the first or second
grade
um I think that this
um
goes against the purpose of the EFA
program which is to provide every
youngster with the options that they
need to succeed and there is no one who
knows what the child needs better than
the parents so requiring them to go to
public school first I think is a
handicap and detrimental
possibly to the child as well as the
program
further discussion representative
Belcher then represent leckis and then
thank you Mr chair you know in the wake
of uh recent Supreme Court precedent
that found that it is unconstitutional
that if a state is to provide a private
school funding through any means that
they must also provide that same funding
to a student seeking a religious
education
there will surely be students If This
Were to pass that are seeking a
religious education while we are
separately funding
through EFA programs other students who
were in non-public schools
this would be unconstitutional on its
face I believe and as I think we all
understand a right delayed is a right
denied
thank you
represent leckis
two comments on this
um
one this this
would force children who had already
started out in a public school and found
that it just didn't work
for whatever reason it may be they just
couldn't deal with that many people in
one place at one time
whatever reason
they've already made that decision
they've already left and now you're
forcing them to go back no no
if they're not in the EFA they're not
grandfathered
right
if they're if they're just at home or in
a small in a small school and they're
not using the EFA but they decide they
would like to in order to get that EFA
they would have to go back to the public
school yeah I mean this is a question
about education choice so if they've
already made the choice and to to uh to
not be in public school and they're not
part of the EFA program then that's a
choice that they that they've already
made this this this bill is simply you
know doing what the what the
commissioner of Education what what do
you what do you what he's what he sold
you know
um you know the uh the legislature two
years ago when when bringing up this
program and putting into the budget that
it
provided students and families with a
with a choice and uh and so so you know
this right now it's it's it's the the
program simply stated has turned into a
free tuition paid for about public tax
taxpayers for people that were already
in private schools and not costing
taxpayers a dime and um and this you
know I I I think had the commissioner
actually said that of the um whatever
we've got now 3 200 uh students that
just about all of them uh were either
already in uh public already in private
schools or going to attend private
schools anyway that that this program
wouldn't have gotten any traction at all
so it's all part of providing
accountability transparency and
oversight to the to the program putting
on some guard rails that that that
protect uh uh the taxpayer and live up
to you know what the what the what the
commissioner said when the program was
established and um and in fact I think I
mentioned it during the hearing that the
the exact language that's in here was
taken from an amendment to Senate Bill
193 back in 2018 yeah absolute same
subject offered by Representatives lad
wolf and cordelli so so there's nothing
there's nothing new here uh other than
um than looking to looking to protect
the Integrity of of a program that
provides choice for students and not
just
um you know free tuition on taxpayer
dimes may I continue
yeah there was a question so he
responded to the question representative
and it was it wasn't meant to be a
question except that you said I was
wrong and I was making sure that I was
reading the bill correctly
um
I don't see how this in response I don't
see how this gives any more transparency
or anything saying a child has to go to
a public school but
my point was this was tried in other
states when somebody objected to a new
program I believe it was actually a
charter school program and well it's
been tried multiple times so it was
various different programs when they
tried the
um you have to go to a public school for
a year first
all these kids
suddenly signed up for public schools it
was a disaster they signed up for the
public schools the public schools
weren't ready for all these kids they
signed up right at the last moment they
it the schools then the states that did
this or the towns that did this
got rid of those laws because it proved
to be a disaster for the communities and
the local schools and it either for this
or in one case it was just to get books
he had to go to the public school to get
the books and so an entire this was in
Chicago an entire
um
all the people going to religious
schools all signed up to get books it's
just it's been tried and it's a mess
number one and number two I don't
understand the least bit how going to a
public school gives any transparency
whatsoever to the program what it has to
do with the program
it's I mean what what can we see because
a kid went to a public school for a year
or guide rails or any of the other
things you said I don't see how this
does any any of that
smile you had your hand up and then
represented right thank you very much
um
this is the first of a series of bills
that are coming before us on your face
this legislature has not had an
opportunity to debate
the issue of efa's
we recall that this program is put into
the back of the budget
did not have a full disclosure as a
matter of fact we've had conversations
about this earlier in other sessions and
this committee basically tabled the
motion because of the questions that we
had
now we had an opportunity here the
numbers are close we all know that we've
all been said by our respective
leadership yeah best show up because we
don't know what's going to happen
so we had an opportunity here
to put a repeal of this bill in
we chose not to do that
what we chose to do is to try to provide
as representative Lynnwood said some
guide rails for this program
so that whatever it is it can be
effective
we recognize that there are students who
are benefiting from the program
but right now there is no oversight to
the damn program
there is no oversight for taxpayer
monies that are going into this program
all we are trying to do through this
series of issues
is to provide some sense of rational
oversight
and some Focus for the program
this is just one of several that are
going to become before us
and we will have this debate on the
floor obviously but I wanted the
committee just to know that we've made
the decision to try to provide these
guide rails for the program rather than
trying to repeal the program because
frankly we might be able to be
successful if the right numbers are
there we chose not to do that
so as these bills come before you I
would hope we would be able to have the
debate
that we haven't had in the past
to really flush this out to see how we
can make sure that there are at least
some sense of oversight some sense of
rational approach to this particular
program thank you Mr chair you're
welcome representative dry thank you Mr
chairman uh
in the course of my homeschooling career
I helped a lot of families make a
transition to homeschooling whether
they've moved from out of state or
whether they are involved in public
schools
Christmas vacation is a really nice time
if you're going to change direction to
stop and and pick up in the new year at
a different direction the homeschooling
laws in New Hampshire make it easy to do
that and the families that arrive at
that decision are making a
a smoother break and change of direction
as they possibly can I wonder how making
a student like that makes a student
who's made that decision stay for
another half of a year is helpful to
further discussion representative
cordelli uh thank you excuse me
representative go ahead and then we'll
thank you
um
I'm also wondering about a student who
moves from Maine or Vermont where they
have choice they have the oldest town
oldest forms of choice Town tuitioning
programs in both States in one case
dating back to the 1800s
um
we would be forcing that child coming to
New Hampshire to spend at least one year
in a public school
where they might be moving
um just across the border to go to a
private school of some sort in New
Hampshire
um so I think that's unfair to that
child and
um
I'm not sure in the bill what is meant
by who's currently attending
for a minimum of one year
I'm not sure what that means so
um uh do you spend one year
and what happens after that one year
because you're not currently attending
anymore
um but I think my main point is for
those children moving from Maine or
Vermont or any other state that has a
choice program I don't think we're being
fair to those families and it might even
discourage families from moving to New
Hampshire
representative woodcock
hey channel that
um I have to disagree with
representatively I don't really give it
to him while people come from Maine
Vermont I'm concerned about the kids we
have here you said when you open up
Glenn this is an off to the need to
succeed there's a handicap
um this bill was this bill was
predicated as a low income option for
kids it didn't get the same break uh and
as we know that's not what we had we had
eight percent of the kids in the initial
year of the program never ever attended
a public school they were already in
private schools so this is a tuition
piece for private schools
my concern is that
it's not an option to determine how the
parents are going to succeed if they've
never tried Public School
they've never tried public school so how
do you know is an option is not going to
work
because they hear it about from their
neighbor or something else no so this is
not it doesn't even come close to me or
it's supposed to be doing in terms of
that I think this this allows and this
if you if to follow there's a better
option let them try public school if it
doesn't work then fine they have an
option that's the least they can do this
is public school
I'm just concerned about students who
may have been going to
private school
you know for years and then uh because
of financial hardship in their family
perhaps the parent loses a job or
there's just medical who knows financial
hardship then uh
they must
go to the public school then they can't
they don't have a choice so I just
wanted to bring that up because that can
happen so I don't think it's fair to
them
I I'd like to ask one thing you know I
haven't had a chance to get into this
what about a child that's
um currently in a DFA program and
there's another youngster coming along
in the family and now we have this in
place
could they both receive vfas or would
one have to you know one continue with
the EFA and the other be forced to go
attend kindergarten or first grade for
the time that's necessary before they
could get an EFA that will make it very
it's a real hardship on a family so so I
can answer that um for you Mr chair so
there is an exception in here
um or who is entering kindergarten or
first grade so so if um if you're a
student whose older sibling uh is an EFA
student and now the younger sibling is
entering kindergarten or first grade
that would qualify them to um uh to have
a education Freedom account
see I've been having a hard time reading
and really trying to figure out what
this this sentence says yeah so so again
you know this this neither your words
representative lad from an amendment
well I think that's called several ways
it's a lot younger back so so the the
way the way the way I parse this as the
as the sponsor of it
um so uh uh established for an eligible
student who is currently attending a New
Hampshire Public School including
Charter Public School for a minimum of
one year that's one portion of it Orr
who is entering kindergarten or first
grade
so that's an eligible student
who is entering kindergarten or first
grade
thank you
representative uh cardelli in the uf10
Belcher thank you
um unlike uh previous uh speaker
um I care about the kids in New
Hampshire but I also care about the kids
and the families who want to come here I
care about them also it's not one of the
other for me I care about them all
represent Belcher
yes thank you Mr chair and I appreciate
that clarification from representative
luno because it it brings me to an
oddity within this bill the idea that
we're going to force a student accept
those who are entering at kindergarten
or first grade to stay for a year
strongly suggest this bill is tailored
toward those who have already been in
am I wrong in that if if those
kindergarten and first graders or yeah I
mean I think that's what the
commissioner of Education said is that
this gives students who are who are
already in public school an option to um
to go to private school to Home School
do uh do some other option but as we've
as we've found out it appears that only
about
um 60 students a year
um have um have you know have actually
you know made the made the choice based
on having a voucher to exit their Public
School
take a voucher and and do another option
everybody else everybody else was either
already in a private school or home
school or going to go to private home
school private school or home school
anyway you can take a look at the
Department's own census data on um on
homeschooling on private schooling those
numbers aren't going up
um so so the the 3200 kids the private
school and home school numbers didn't go
up by 3 200. these kids were already in
or going to go uh anyway and so this is
this has simply been
um uh coming on I think 25 million
dollars of of of of taxpayer money to
pay private school tuition bill or
homeschool costs for these kids and
another request that 60 million coming
down the pike in the in the current
budget right now it's not moving kids
out of um out of out of public school
which isn't it which is exactly the
intent
as it was presented by the commissioner
of this program to begin with so this
this simply puts the program back on the
tracks that it was supposed to be on
sir follow-up yes please just to clarify
then and thank you for that
clarification so to be clear the the
point of the program is that students
who are already in public school and who
have done okay in public school
seemingly because they've stayed there
for a while they're the ones who would
be allowed to leave who are probably the
most unlikely to leave but those who
have already left because they probably
may have had problems those are the ones
who would have to go back for a year
that's that was the point I was making
then left though the point Mike
they hadn't left they've never been
there that was a point
eighty percent of the kid never been
there
represent Lucas you had your end up or
did you not yeah
I did and it was for a couple of things
I'm trying to follow the logic
yeah
if they're only the people who can go
who can have this Choice are those who
are already in public school unless you
haven't been to public school yet
I mean what is the I don't understand
that logic if you want them to have
experienced Public School
why do they have a choice if they're
entering kindergarten or first grade
they haven't experienced Public School
I I don't it's completely illogical to
me can you explain the logic because I'm
not understanding you say one thing
you want them attending the public
school and or leaving
only give the choice to those who will
be leaving the public school but then
you say but if they haven't been to the
public school yet they get a choice
so thanks thanks for the question
um you know I think it's I think it's
pretty simple uh that the that the bill
is providing choice to students and
families as their students uh are are
you know come of age to go into a
kindergarten or first grade they can
they can sign up for it for in for an
EFA or if they're already in second
third or fourth grade or fifth grade or
tenth grade and say hey you know what
um uh uh or actually let me pick uh let
me pick eighth grade because a lot of
you know I think I have to look at the
the
um the yearly Census Data from the from
the department but but you know
attending public eighth grade and then
private school for for high school
that's an option that uh that many
students
um not a huge number but many students
in New Hampshire take so you may find
that a student has um has gone K-8 in
public school cool and then it's like
hey you know what the the voucher
program the fa program provides me with
with funds that that help me bridge the
gap to uh to attend private school for
high school and so so I I I'm I'm not
quite sure I I understand what your what
Your what your concern is with this
other than as as it you know might
relate to uh kids that have have you
know families that have already made the
choice to enter a non to go to a
non-public school which wasn't the
intent of the uh the program that was
um if you look at the numbers it's
actually 40 something percent who were
at some point in a public school and
then are not now in a public school the
20 is just of the start of the year of
the start of the program
um
a number left during covet a number left
before that and what I want to know what
so you're
it seems to me that what you're saying
is that a student for whom Public School
really was not working out to the point
that the parent felt that they needed to
withdraw the student
but the parent is now struggling to
provide home education
to pay for the things that the student
needs
is struggling but they still would
prefer to struggle then send the child
back to the public school we're saying
because you took your child out of
public school
before the EFA program started you now
can't qualify for the EFA program so you
have to keep going on and struggling
because you made that choice before the
okay I I sure yeah I'm just not aware of
any comments made by the commissioner of
Education uh when uh when when uh
selling the EFA program that that's what
that's who it was designed for I don't
recall a single comment from the
commissioner to that effect I I have a
question with line three in the bill
right now too
um
who is currently attending a New
Hampshire Public School
we have New Hampshire students going to
public schools in Vermont
which are approved
by the Department of Education here
and
it's the only choice they currently have
in the district they're being sent from
I'm talking about Monroe sending all the
kids to St Johnsbury Academy for high
school a student goes there and says
that I don't like this I want to have an
EFA
can they do it
so so that that's a great question I
think you know we've gotta we've gotta
go back to the fact that you know the
statutes are sort of at the 30 000 foot
level and rules are at the at the ground
level and um uh 194 F does give the
Department of Education rule making
Authority uh surrounding the program so
I think um I think you know in rules uh
with respect to applications to the EFA
program they could certainly um I think
within the within the spirit of this of
of this section uh include public
schools that are approved by um uh by
the by the Department of Education and
that that would certainly include
um uh schools that may be operated in
other states but but considered to be
New Hampshire you know public schools
for New New Hampshire Public School
students I think that falls within rule
making the rule-making realm
um uh because they you know it is sort
of a
you know sort of an edge case
here but a valid one Mr chair and and I
think I think that would fall into rules
and then I would go one step further and
say okay we're talking about New
Hampshire Public School yeah we're
talking about
An approved School
but we also have private schools that
are approved by Doe as well
so should we be saying a New Hampshire
approved public or private school
so thanks I don't think I don't think I
mean there's obviously a number of
students who are attaching attending New
Hampshire public and private schools and
and I think the the intent behind this
bill is that is that these are public
school students who uh whose families
who whose students and their families
would like to have a um they're
attending public schools and they'd like
to have a choice to do uh to do
something else and they meet the the
income eligibility uh guidelines uh uh
income eligibility standards as well uh
so uh so you know if the student is
currently attending
private school in New Hampshire I I I I
I don't think that's what the that's not
what the commissioner was talking about
I don't think that's what the tax base
I'm going to stop a little bit more
under our tuition program that we we
passed the the receiving school that's
being sent from a district which is
tuitioning is approved not by the doe
it's approved by the local Board of
Education as you know so I I believe
that there there to read this properly
it really needs say a New Hampshire
approved public or private school if
we're going to enable the student that's
coming from a tuition District such as a
pyrmont
that does all their tuitioning of kids
outside now and that's a many many
districts in the state do that except
wouldn't that defeat the purpose of the
bill by by saying that there if they're
already attending a private school then
they can apply for a uh an EFA well
maybe they're upset with that private
school and they said no I'm just not
ready to go in EFA program it's going to
fit what's going on with our family and
it's a better fit so
I see it seems to me we're saying it's
okay to do it if it's a public but for
the private it's yeah and I think that's
discriminatory yeah I I mean I I I think
so long as as long as the private school
wasn't a
um a private that the that the choice
the family had made to go to a private
school was
um was a district Choice as opposed to I
mean we're really sort of getting Beyond
I think what what you can how you can
carve out every possible
you know permutation in in in statute
um you know I think you're I think
um Rick you're probably talking about
about a public school district that uses
a private school for I'm talking about
the tuition program which we have yeah
yeah but that's a public separate
Academy in Vermont or St Johnsbury
Academy or but it's done those are
independent but it's done through the
public school district to meet to meet
the school
proof approved by the local board yes
and it's locally approved rather than
approved private or public school in New
Hampshire it's locally approved right
it's locally approved but that Public
School District even though they're
getting the the receiving Services
through through a private school has to
comply with all of the public school
um
um uh regulations both state and federal
uh they so they're they're they're not
able to operate as as a private school
that
you know does not have a yeah outside of
the book you know correct it's correct
yeah so so I just don't know how you put
that all in statute Rick
if you look at the tuition that's the
tuition
approval process which we put in place
they have to comply with many of the
rules that we have like fire code Safety
Code building code all those types of
things they do not have to comply
necessarily with all the other aspects
that's that's a local board decision
read it well they'd have to comply with
idea yeah well yes yes
they'd have to do they have to take
testing
I'd have to go yeah I don't know the
answer I don't know if that's exactly
the case either it's something we that
you got to go check I think that that
there possibly are some holes here with
the way this has been written that's
what I'm trying to say that it needs to
be clear and and I I think not
conflicting with other areas of of uh
programming which we have provided the
local board and even the State Board to
approve
represent cordelli thank you
um and I'm not sure where the concept of
the commissioner selling this program
came in this program was put into place
by the legislature by the general court
so any statements made by the
commissioner or anyone else after the
fact were clearly based on experiences
in other states
who were not in the middle of a pandemic
also so
um to say that this Commit This
commissioner sold this program I don't
think is accurate this program was put
into place by the general court period
okay representative yeah I totally
disagree with that the commissioner sat
right down in the finance office the
finance room and basically made his
pitch this is where he said it was only
going to cost 130 000 so don't tell me
that he did not make a pitch publicly on
this he absolutely did to this
legislature
that was on supplemental money
no it was on efas it's in the budget
program though that was a use of federal
dollars which were coming down to have
the permission to use those dollars for
this program no you're talking about the
40 40 40 plus a million I'm talking way
before that Rick okay okay way before
that he made that pitch to the finance
committee
we're representative McDowell thank you
I've been listening carefully and to
address the points made in this corner
of the room about this varying from the
commissioner's intent although he was a
supporter of the program I see that as
irrelevant to this because this bill and
other EFA related bills I believe those
12 are in front of our committee and
it's our decision right now as to the
betterment of this program and the
future of it so I don't understand those
concerns regarding from it varying from
someone's initial intent would you like
to explain that further because it just
to me seems irrelevant to what we're
oh sure um yeah the uh the I you know I
think I think going to intent is is very
important and uh and I think uh uh we
look at at legislative intent all the
time and one of the biggest policy
documents in fact I would argue the
largest policy document that this
legislature in every legislature does
every year
um is contained within two bills hb1 and
hb2 and uh hb2 actually contains all of
the in fact it is the only place in
statute where um uh where 194 F was uh
was created and this is the statute that
creates the education Freedom account
program and uh and the um uh hb1 and hb2
together the uh the state budget uh are
basically based on presentations that
the finance committee uh takes from
department heads from uh from
Commissioners from
um uh from the chancellors at the at the
community college system and University
system and from others uh plus they they
hear from members of the public uh as
well and you can specifically look at
the the spreadsheet
um and I'm forgetting what the
department called it I think they call
it a very detailed spreadsheet or
something like that on on exactly how
many students where they would be from
and what the state uh expense estimate
would be uh would be for that and um and
and the St the students basically all
came from public schools none came from
from private schools and um and and uh
and that's what was presented and so it
is that that was the legislative intent
it's in the budget
um tied with the only place where the
where the statute was created and um and
you know I'll you know I might argue
until blue in the face but but but I
would I would certainly say that that
there was no argument presented to the
uh the finance committee or anybody else
uh two years ago
um when the budget was being written
that uh that this would be about uh
picking up uh tuition taxpayers picking
up tuition bills for kids that were
already in private schools
further discussion
represent Damon
thank you Mr chair I actually wanted to
go back to the earlier
to the chairs
um situation of
students who are already going for
example to St Johnsbury or Thetford
Academy a
private school that's used as a public
school that districts tuition their
students to
would it be correct that since those
students are already enrolled in those
schools
and
their school system is already paying
tuition for them they don't need an EFA
now the the question was that I had is
they want to leave and take an EFA and
this says a New Hampshire Public School
that they want okay and these are not
New Hampshire schools but they are
recognized and approved by
New Hampshire doe or Montpelier
and the interstate agreements allow that
to occur touch
yes I believe the words that you said
were legislative intent not
Commissioners intent and this bill did
not come from the commissioner it came
from legislators it came from a lot of
us who had worked on it for a long time
when it was presented we present we
there was no cap so it was certainly not
aimed just for people coming from the
public school to the private school to
or to wherever there was no cap there
was a lot of discussion as to whether or
not there should be a cap that was put
in later before it got put in the bill I
mean into the sb2
this alleged this initiated
from the legislature
it was argued by the legislature there
were lots of arguments including whether
or not there should be a cap whether or
not this was something every student was
entitled to as part of adequacy to all
of our students
and this was intended to help provide
adequacy to all of our students
including those for whom a public school
did not work
it was that's that was its intent if
you're talking about intent
by the time it got to yes people were
making based estimates
their best estimates based on
what we've seen in other states that was
all we had to go on the estimate was
that most private school I mean most
homeschoolers were not going to want to
and a lot of homeschoolers have not did
not want to get involved with the
government in order to get money and
then all the strings that are attached
and many homeschoolers still do not want
to do that and did not apply
um
but they were looking at other states
but that is not you can't take I can't
take one person coming in here and
testifying what they think I I something
is going to happen as the intent of the
legislature
and and so you keep going back to the
intent of the commissioner the intent of
the commissioner the intent of the
commissioner
and which have you even asked has he
said what isn't that his intent was just
that no
yes that was their money estimates based
on what we'd seen in other schools but
this is our Legend this this was our
bill the legislators bill
a lot of us worked on it it was and and
Senate
the general court this was our bill we
had intent it doesn't matter what the
commissioner did or didn't intend
that is not anything to do with what we
are deciding what we did decide and what
we will decide
we want legislative
get your red light on over there repson
Woodcock oh
you're welcome uh represent Belcher I'll
be brief
um
So based on what we've heard I think
it's pretty clear that the or part of
the intent behind the bill is that there
is a feeling that students who have
accessed uh private or not public
schooling
should not then be able to access
because these funds because they've
already were already in that program
however I have yet to hear any ethical
or moral argument why a student who is a
resident of our state who has parents
who are taxpayers of our state is not
entitled to a share of what amounts to I
think at this point maybe roughly 20
percent of the typical costs to educate
a public student why they don't have the
right to access that money even if they
were already
representative yes because the state has
has an obligation to provide education
for kids and they have chosen that
public schools is their obligation
parents who choose to go elsewhere
that's their choice clearly but it's not
based upon taxpayers monies going in
that direction
so the obligation for the state to
provide a public uh anchored well
education education for students is
through the public school system and the
public charter school system that is the
choices this state has made so your
issue around parents they have all the
choice they want to they can stay in the
public schools they can go elsewhere but
the issue is where is the taxpayer money
going to go and that taxpayer money has
been determined by the state that is
through a public school system
and and I would uh
go the opposite way on that
representative Miler I would say
compulsory attendance which is statutory
and created by us the legislature the
people of the State of New Hampshire say
there's four ways to get your education
public
private homeschooling efas
and there are four legs of the required
compulsory attendance in our state
represent uh cordelli no thank you uh
going back to the Senate and what went
into the budget
um the Senate bill that
was the source of the language in
hb2
did not restrict
the program to public school children
for any period of time
an eligible student was defined as in a
student who was eligible to enroll in a
public elementary or secondary school
plus the income cap
there was no
um
I'm not sure about there were two
Democrat sponsored floor amendments to
the bill I'm not sure what the content
was but both were defeated so in terms
of this
legislation that we're looking at in HB
430 and the requirement to attend a
public school was not the intent of what
was put into the budget
is there any further discussion on this
not saying any um we have a
motion on the floor the motion is to
itl HB 430 it was made by representative
cordelli
and with that I'm not seeing any further
discussion on it Madam clerk would you
please call the roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonnell definitely yes representative
Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Myler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative Woodcock news
representative Hall no representative
Balboni no representative Fox no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
10 years 10 knees Mr chair I move out to
pass
is there a second I'll second that okay
represent uh luno moves on to pass
second by represent Tanner
any discussion on that
yeah
yes thank you okay Mike when you
prepared uh call the roll please face
emotion is to OTP
Vice chairman cordelli
no no
representative like us no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonnell no way
representative Noble no representative
pedernal
no Representative cortielo no
representative miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Wilcox yeah
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative Fox yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
okay and represent Cordelia I'm assuming
well we got one down folks
okay yeah that's right exactly
um
I'm just going to keep moving right up
HB 367 eligibility
this is a bill that's been put forth by
representative Lucas
relative eligibility of students
education Freedom account program
it's basically a bill remember if you
remember going up to the 500 percent
from 300 to 500 as far as eligibility
that's the change in this uh this bill
is there a motion
we're in 367
um
yeah I thought representative I was
looking at you were playing this way
sounds like us yes I I move OTP please
second
okay we have a motion for OTP on three
six seven uh made by representative
leckis and second by represent McDonald
uh any discussion representative lekkis
technically
I the 300 cap we have eliminated many
people who are actually in need
including the middle class who are
always in need because
they are not eligible for scholarships
they are not but don't make enough money
to provide the education that their
child actually needs and so this is to
reach out to the middle class who got
cut off
by the 300 percent cap
who still can't afford to get the
education their children need and yet
cannot apply for scholarships or any
other Aid because they make too much and
this happens all the time they make too
much but not enough thank you
represent McDonald do you have any
discussion I'll keep this brief but to
the discussion on the previous Bill
about legislative intent as I am aware
of those initial discussion with the EFA
program as it was passed not to have an
income gap so this would be closer to
legislative intent as representative
luno suggested was so important a few
minutes ago thank you thank you very
much represent cordelli you're
recognized uh
thank you Mr chairman um I do have an
amendment for when would be the
appropriate time to present it and now
it's the appropriate time thank you
um I'll pass this around
okay
thank you
um I'll proceed with the discussion on
it because it's very simple
it reduces the
um
once you move it oh sorry
23-0226h I'll second it
can I yes thank you
um this is a very simple Amendment
um
it changes the uh original bills
increase of the income cap from 500
um we have heard
um
recently in in relation to one of the
School Meal program bills about
um the fact that
um the free and reduced lunch
income cap should be raised to 300
percent for everybody because of the
inflation and the difficult time people
um were having to
cope with everything that's going on in
terms of prices
from the grocery store to the gas
station to housing
and I think the same applies for the
education Freedom account bill
um
uh I don't have with me the number but
we did hear testimony about I think it
was several hundred people had applied
for efas but we're over the income cap
some by most of those I think were under
ten thousand dollars over the 300
percent cap
this would help those families
and
the 300 percent for a family of two a
single mother and a child is currently
um at 300 percent and goes up by less
than ten thousand dollars to sixty four
thousand eighty five dollars that's for
a family of two for a family of four it
goes from eighty three thousand two
hundred and fifty to ninety seven
thousand one twenty five
so I I think that this is um
hopefully will be seen as a reasonable
uh compromise to help those
um families who have been struggling
with the increased prices
um and maybe uh declining family income
to be able to qualify for the program
thank you very much is is there a
further discussion from committee on
this represent Woodcock and thank you
General Clinton uh the 97 125 is that
um is that the 350 novel yeah I'm sorry
I'm sorry yes through 350 for a family
of four okay thank you thank you
Madam clerk I see no further discussion
on this would you please call the roll
on
uh zero two two six H which is an
chairman cardelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Petrino
yes
representative courtiello yes
representative Myler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no Representative
balvoni no representative Fox no
representative Damon
yes
represent cordelli thank you I would
like to move a lot to pass as amended
let's see ma'am clerk would you please
call the roll
represent I'm sorry Vice chairman
cordelli yes
yes
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford yeah representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative Corey Taylor yes
representative Myler no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Wilcox no representative Paul no
representative Balboni no
representative Fox no
chairman Ladd yes
10 years 10 days
Mr chairman Rex and Miley recognize
uh uh represent my recommend uh makes
the motion of itl on this bill and
Vice chairman excuse me Vice chairman
cordelli
no
representative Lucas
no representative Ford
no
representative Belcher no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no
representative Peter now no
representative of course yellow no
representative Myler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Allison yep
representative Wilcox yeah
representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative Fox yes
yes
chairman Ladd no
10 years 10 Nays
so once again uh you'll be writing
report
represent Luna thank you and Rick um
what's the first one we've had where
there was a motion
ought to pass a Amendment yes
amended failed so that means the
amendment is no is not a committee
Amendment it's not it's it's the
position of the folks that voted for
this to ought to pass seeing that it was
approved by the committee but it's not
it
it'll be written up in the committee
report but that's as far as the goal is
there's no committee uh it's not a
committee Amendment there's no Amendment
coming out of committee it's just a
position that representative clay Valley
will incorporate into his you know
report correct yeah yeah the bill the
bill has not been amended in commitment
that's correct right right so this is
sort of new territory well I've been
here once once before in another bill
years ago and that's that's you know
yeah
similar situation but um
per episode I'm just going to write that
and you're going to write the other
right
okay that leaves two bills left for
today we're getting there
moving up the ladder here we're looking
at
HB 131
classroom recording policies I'm not
going to get that and get the full title
here
okay
one three one
does anybody have to take a break here
for I I yeah I'm with you representative
Cornell
ah
uh thank you Mr chair this is House Bill
131 requiring reports concerning school
policies on classroom recordings and in
classroom observers and a call on the
second by representative miler
uh representative miler oh that's true
any further discussion
looks like everyone wants to get home so
Vice chairman cordelli
no
motion is itl
no idea
representative Ford
yeah
representative Belcher
yes
representative dry yes
representative McDonnell yes
representative Noble
no
representative pedernal
Representative cortielo no
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd
yes
does anyone want to write a Minority
Report
representative thank you I moved
second
yes reading my notes from this
bill it was the fact that
the results are one printed on the
department of Ed website and two every
report of the fiscal committee had to
include names addresses dollar amount
students and they had to report looking
every three months it was December and
November and March and February and it
was a lot of reports that aren't
required of other public schools and so
the hence the repeal of the
this section that called for a number of
reports
in effect it'll it's covered in one
yearly report there was no need to do
my understanding is because it's in the
RSA and then that's why they want to
so this this applies to what the fiscal
committee receives rather than the
education committee receives and I'm
just since we have nobody here from
fiscal
um I'm just wondering and and charter
schools are a uh under the non-profit
um rules of the State uh and are managed
by a board of directors it
shouldn't we have I just don't
understand why we have it I had wished
you'd vacated it to fiscal but um I'm
just wondering why those those two
things don't add up that perhaps that's
why they they have the reporting so
often and that it was a you know
a program that
had to I don't think
I don't think they have the same
requirements as a public school as far
as the funding is concerned so
um and it may be something fiscal needs
I yes I think we've been through the
funding mechanism for the public charter
schools but also this goes to my reading
of as it goes to the fiscal committee
rather than Finance which is a different
ball game in itself the fiscal committee
that could you explain it there is a
legislative fiscal committee that meets
I think on a monthly basis
um uh versus the state excuse me versus
the house or Senate Finance committees
there it's a separate body it's a joint
they approve various new funding
mechanisms grants things that come up
during the course of the year
let me go ahead and explain that a
little bit fiscal uh is a committee
which last year was chaired by represent
umberger it was pretty well split you
know with Republican Democrat when I
chair the as chair of the commission for
the public school infrastructure Monies
and that's you know that's totaled
well we're up around 40 43 million
dollars which we've had to allocate out
with the last several years all combined
together
the the public school infrastructure
committee makes a recommendation for how
these where the monies will go to which
districts
then what fiscal does is they then the
the recommendation has to go to fiscal
for clearance to ensure that we're
spending money that we have
that's available and then then from
fiscal the public school
structure monies would then by Statue
have to go to Governor Council for
approval
so fiscal is a committee is Watchdogs
available dollars and which will also
approve Grant monies which come in we
talked about that 40 million dollars
earlier and fiscal was not in the
business of of approving that it's not
division two it's or three or one which
is how the finance committee this is
made up of members from finance that act
on to ensure monies are available and
how they're how they're used
um in many cases it's joint Senate and
House
so with with public charter schools uh
some of them haven't been physically
um
able to to make it I mean there's been
at least one I know that's gone uh
because of phys financial things that
was a charter conversion school yeah and
and I think there were a couple others
that had physical problems and would
this watchdog
uh committee actually be helpful in
seeing when a charter was getting close
to having a financial problem and be
able is that one no that's not one of
the responsibilities they are they only
look at expenditures in in the use of
monies the oversight that they're not an
oversight committee like we have for so
many of like
Improvement and assessment we have an
oversight committee yeah
thank you very different represent like
us
when we had that meeting at
um Granite State College and we asked
that question they said that this law
was put in when they had first started
doing charter schools and they had no
idea how the whole thing would work and
that at this point it's all taken care
of otherwise and that was not needed
anymore
further further questions
true yes representative enough yeah
thank you very much Mr chair so
the um you know as the as the department
I think had had mentioned during the
hearing
um history 71 repeals
paragraph e in 194 b11 won Roman one
um so submit a report to fiscal many two
of the general court for each payment
made in a fiscal year by the state to a
chartered public school pursuant to
some paragraph C talks about how the how
the department
um shall calculate payments made to
Charter Schools and the first payment
shall be 30 percent of the per pupil
amount multiplied by and it goes It goes
on there
um is is that report is there is the
department of education required to
submit that report by Statute anywhere
else
um because they they do submit the
I don't have the answer to that I I
don't either
um yeah so I I just I don't know why why
where we're repealing
um reports that have to do with the use
of taxpayer money to support Public
Schools
go ahead representative I'm just
wondering what
reports do public school traditional
Public Schools submit to the fiscal
committee on a monthly basis
well the the pub the school doesn't so
the public schools don't submit it and
the the Charter Public Schools don't
submit it either it's the commissioner
of of Education the Department of
Education that that submits uh these
reports and um and and you know as they
so that's that's it it's not I mean
Public Schools
I have to file tons of reports with the
Department of Education and and it's up
to the you know in in this case the the
charter schools are
um receiving
their their their grants essentially
their grants over and above the the cost
of inadequate education from the state
and uh and I and it sounds like this is
what
that report
that report it's doing I mean it's
ensuring that the that the commissioner
yes how else do we know well I I from my
notes on representative Mooney's
testimony is that this was a 20 000 in
2016 law change but the report is moot
now because of the ability
um for
um a warrant article to be drawn anytime
there is the need for funds in terms of
the education trust fund well wouldn't
we want to have wouldn't the report
contain that that additional funds
um drawn by the governor on a warrant
and and I don't think I don't think the
part that's being repealed was the 2016
law I think I mean I'm looking at my
notes and I'm saying 2016 a lot of
change and what was changed
and and and I agree using representative
Mooney's words makes the report moved
but I'm not but there was no reference
to to what what that was and what
actually requires
any report to be made available on the
I'm just you know I I I I think that the
fiscal committee does get status reports
on the
um status of various funds including the
education trust fund because I I've
gotten information from them
um about the Surplus and so forth yeah
I've got I've got that that's that's
contained in the kafir the annual report
as well but but it doesn't break it down
um
the way the way certainly the the um the
the Department of Education breaks down
payments to everything I think what I'm
going to do on this is that this is not
an early Bill okay it seems like there
are some questions yeah I I'm familiar
with fiscal but I I I've never you know
they meet on Fridays and I don't really
do that right so so what we can do is we
can you know just recess this bill get
some folks in from fiscal and and and
and doe as well it just get some answers
so it may be just very simple thing to
resolve but I too it's like signing a
check and not what we're doing knowing
what we're doing here and not reading
the fine print so I would like to know
more so that's fair enough so let's just
recess this and not get a gut ache on it
right now and and drive home in some
light
so thank you very much we are adjourned
for the day I think tomorrow we've
talked about
um his lunch and then we're going to
caucus yeah okay yeah what time do
the session starts at what time
Sports in the afternoon schedule why am
I losing anything because you read your
yeah right yeah we talked about doing
that talking yeah all right so we're so
we're nine o'clock in the calf so we're